all right good morning everybody
um
glad to notice that we have a quorum and
I'm opening the public hearing on hcr2
thank you chair members of the committee
I'm here to today present uh
house soon resolution number two
and uh I can be very brief I think
and uh pardon my word processing and
it's been two days without electric at
as a teacher
I used to look over my class and see
what students had uh names that I needed
to learn first
uh and as a business adventure as a bit
of an adventurous student myself
I could sometimes understand their
struggle
but it was not until I was a parent
myself
that I realized that every child had a
parent that possibly loved their child
as much as I love mine
these students were my lesson in
compassion and forgiveness
this bill before you was not a gotcha
legislation
it isn't meant to make anyone look bad
it's our joint opportunity to practice a
little that compassion and forgiveness
that I still believe is so lacking in
it won't erase past statements or made
on both sides of the aisle hopefully
though it will allow us to move beyond
our own toxic Behavior as we all strive
to be better versions of ourself
and that pretty much I think sums up but
I hope this amendment is about
I'm willing to say questions thank you
very much are there any questions from
the committee
ah
all right representative O'Brien thank
you madam chair uh and representative
thank you for taking my question uh I'm
just briefly in my overview of this
what's different in this bill as
compared to common law on vandalism and
everything
and you know I don't see fines and I
think that's also codified and some
already existing state law
if you could explain that please I would
agree with you and I think that um as
far as
um
laws against this type of behavior I
think they're probably fairly
when enforced I think they're probably
will do the job we want but this is not
a bill to enact legislation this is a
resolution and I believe that's
doesn't carry quite the legislative
teeth that a bill would carry and that
would be my intent to not carry those
teeth I think this is more of a moment
for us to all reflect on where we'd like
to go as a legislative body
I think we all agree there has has been
a bit of acrobatic acrimony in the past
within the chamber
and uh I think the fortunate thing about
resolutions is they generally do stay
within the chamber
uh they're not considered by other
bodies and they are often not used to
enact laws
I think that's the advantage of a
resolution in this particular case I
would normally count that as this
advantage
I hope that answers your question it
does thank you
representative a bear
thank you madam chair thank you for
being here
um obviously this is a very important
subject the resolution is in the past
tense so can you speak to that why we
would put a bill in that speaks to the
past tense and
no
it's in the present tense I I you know I
I think it is a good point there thank
you for the question
um
I by the time when this was drafted
there were several incidents some
happening in my own County that were
very fresh in my mind and perhaps at
that time I was considering more the
freshness of those particular events
um weren't I to redraft it I would
definitely consider what you say I
however I don't think it makes the
impact of what this resolution is trying
to do any less significant I would hope
thank you very much representative thank
you
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
on HCR too
all right then I will close the public
hearing
what
okay well in that case we have 25
minutes until our next hearing
so
sorry about the delay
we were chatting uh so I'm opening the
hearing on on house resolution 11 and I
thank you madam chair thank you
committee members for um
being here and I want to give a quick
um history behind this this resolution
was introduced
that last term term before and it was a
HCR and it passed the house uh
um close to unanimous 342 to 10 or
something and because it was a HCR and
the
the Senate did not take up on their side
it died
on the table or having passed the house
so this time I have brought it as a
house resolution only
so basically what it does is
acknowledging that
welcoming communities exist
in United States and I can proudly say
Nashua is one of the first cities
officially becoming welcoming community
and in
State of New Hampshire and
there are five six other communities
that are on the path like Manchester
conquered uh
so basically what this resolution does
is to acknowledge the immigrants
acknowledge their contribution and
acknowledge that a New Hampshire
celebrates diversity just a quick fact
since 20 uh the 2020 census
showed that there are
the diversity or the population change
shift demographic shift happened in New
Hampshire before it used to be 98 White
and then it came down to 95 percent
in the 2020 census showed 86 percent so
and also what the immigrants did to New
Hampshire is helped with keeping the
negative population growth and influx of
younger Workforce into the state
and in Nashua it happened with
um we if the immigrants were not
accounted for we would have 5 000 out of
90 000 population negative growth
and because of the Immigrant population
the 5000 negative
was offset by the immigrants so it's
it's happening
and embrace it and celebrate it and I am
one of the faces of first generation
immigrant and so
you know I'm a productive contributing
citizen served on all aspects Public
um any questions I'm happy to answer as
much as I can
bear
thank you madam chair thank you for
being here and taking my question
um so as I read this bill it
says that you want to urge
public and private businesses to embrace
diversity
um and embrace this welcoming
um can you give an example of
how you believe the state
of New Hampshire should
urge businesses public and private to do
this what is your what are your examples
I can tell you in Nashua greater Nashua
Area Chamber to chamber and I've built
sister city between India one of the
cities that I came from to where I live
and chamber did uh facts or in terms of
how the economic impact of the region so
just if I yeah in Greater Nashua area we
have about six percent Indian American
alone people who look come from where I
come from they contribute they have over
businesses started by them starting from
grocery store uh Salon to high tech and
working and they bring in this was
2015-16 time that time frame they bring
in about
3.5 billion dollars Revenue each year
just the 100 business just this
community so when there is a positive
impact just acknowledging the presence
and that's why Nashua has gone that way
to officially become welcoming and we
have a welcoming celebrity
and when uh you know somebody from India
comes in
yeah so they will you know it's not a
mandatory
policy changes
you know instead of saying go back to
where you come from
acknowledging the fact that we are here
to stay
and we are contributing
so encouraging that
inclusion and acknowledging contribution
I'm I'm trying to
get at how this bill would and I know
you're you're saying this is not a
mandate but the word urge
is not defined here and I I'm curious
where the government's places in
that definition of urging there is it's
not a bill it's a resolution so there's
no implementation of any law or Bill it
is just acknowledging yes we see the
diversity yes it's uh happening and yes
we acknowledge it that's all
acknowledgment of presence of immigrants
and we are a welcoming state
thank you other question to
representative Gerhart
thank you madam chair so the statistics
you used before
you said it went from I forget 100 white
to 96 or down to 86 currently so with
the ideal goal be zero percent White
no right that's really not a an
appropriate question I don't think thank
you madam well I'm just curious the
trend is moving downwards
so that's a good thing that's what we're
establishing no I'm not saying anything
about it I'm just stating the facts uh
representative and there is no motive or
goal to say we want to shift it it is
just I'm here I'm you know my family and
my community is contributing this is an
adopted uh country I'm a citizen voting
Citizen and people like me are existing
acknowledge it that's all
instead of saying go back to where you
come from
good morning
um
being a first generation immigrant
myself
um
this is an encouragement
I would imagine to recognize everyone's
diversity
and the value that they as individuals
bring would you say that would be an
accurate way of describing
to a hundred percent okay thank you
thank you all right thank you other
questions
all right not seeing any thank you very
much representative
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on H.R 11.
I see it's a whole bunch of reps all the
Reps almost from uh Nashua and uh many
are in different I understand that but
there's uh they're not here to
physically
all right if there isn't anyone else who
wishes to speak then I'll close the
foreign
we have another half hour free
at 11 15 is the
okay welcome back everybody I'm opening
the hearing on House Bill 96 and calling
thank you madam chair and members of the
Edna committee uh for the record
representative John petusic from
Rockingham 13 which is Derry New
Hampshire
uh House Bill 96 recognizing May 3rd as
the Old Man of the Mountain day
um
I have a little a little history
uh a while back my wife and I were
sitting at dinner talking and
remembering the old man we used to go up
and down through the notch uh with our
kids visiting uh New Hampshire and
always when we went by always mentioned
that geez it's what New Hampshire is
supposed to be all about
and uh I just thought that it would be
interesting to recognize uh the days
that the old man decided to come down
nobody saw it
nobody heard it
and it's just as if
it was his choice to come down when he
wanted to come down
we don't know if he was there for a
hundred years
or a thousand years
for a million years
it was his choice and the higher being
that decided that it's time to come down
so I had a talk with a representative
shirtless
oh about a year and a half two years ago
about some type of remembrance not a big
whoop-dee-doo holiday just a day of
remembrance if you drive through the
night she'll look up and say oh
that was pretty cool
what do you think about it says yeah
that was very interesting
and uh
just
it was it just
was something that I thought was
appropriate
and then I talked to Senator Bradley
about a year ago he said John that's
that's something I could get behind
and then I talked to uh
representative Packard and he says I
could I could co-sponsor that and also
talk to Senator Susie and she said yeah
I've I've done that myself going up
through the notch look up and say geez
he's missing
so that was my idea uh to have the four
leadership positions
uh be co-sponsors and they all agree
I've broached the subject with uh some
of the media
they approached the subject with the
governor
and the governor said he would
definitely be behind this it's just a
day of remembrance it's not a big
whoop-de-doo holiday like I said just
something that would be on the calendar
I also realized that Edna
being as I'm a four-term member they do
not like to do days
so I understand that it's just that this
would be a nice thing to do for the
people of New Hampshire because it is
remembered
in New Hampshire
the United States
mint
remembered the old man on the quarter
the United States Postal Service
remembered the old man
way back with a three cent stamp I'm old
enough to remember that
so if the United States thought it was
important enough to remember the old man
I think is important enough for us
who live in New Hampshire and have seen
the old man
to remember the old man
and I'd like to close
with a quote
men hang out their signs
indicative of their respective traits
shoemakers hang out a giant shoe
Jewelers a monster watch
and the dentist hangs out a gold tubes
God almighty
has hung out a sign
to show that their he makes men
I thank you for listening to me folks
I appreciate it
if there's any questions
I'd be happy to answer them but I know
there's folks here are going to be
testifying behind me
uh
and I thank you for your attention
doesn't look like it thank you sir thank
you
foreign
good morning thank you madam chairman
chairwoman um I'm Matt Leahy I'm the
public policy director for the society
for the protection of New Hampshire
Forest um I'll be brief we support this
bill
um and I want to thank representative
for bringing it Forward he actually did
a great job
um
stating why this is important so I won't
repeat that but I will just say
um obviously the Old Man of the Mountain
is
go so deep into New Hampshire's
culture and history it's something I
think we're always proud of and I
remember as a kid going up to the Notch
and looking up
to see the old man it's always it was
always very exciting so I again I just
want to reiterate that we support the
bill and we'd appreciate your support of
it
thank you
representative
thank you thank you uh Mr Leahy one of
the concerns that we have when it comes
to days of recognition is that they're
just going to be in a statute never to
be see never to see the light of day
right so does your organization have a
plan on what they would do on this day
uh that's a good question not
necessarily but I will say that and I
won't give you the full history of the
four Society but you know back in the
1920s before Society actually worked
with the state to establish Franconia
Franconia Notch State Park so it's it is
part of our history too so I think we
certainly would want to do things to
um you know promote the day and promote
the importance of
celebrating the old man but so but I
don't have a particular plan right now
in place we haven't come to that but
it's again it's it is part of our
representative
excuse me thank you madam chair a quick
question in terms of since the old man
has
disappeared or he disappeared
hasn't been there the franconian lodge
when you go to see the notch there's
some histories there's some description
and historical perspective of the space
it already exists right yeah so there is
a old man Plaza in the notch
um which is very it's a beautiful spot
we just think this day would kind of add
to what we're what the state is doing to
celebrate the old man thank you follow
up yeah thank you madam chair so is
there anything up on the notch to kind
of commemorate this is what it was to
encourage tourism to go all the way up
you mean in the like a place I mean like
where there used to be I don't believe
Simon
if I can just help with that um there's
a place called profile point right
around profile Lake and there are
depending on your height you can stand
at certain points and they've set stuff
up so that you can see the old man as it
would have been on the mountain so you
can kind of experience what it was like
uh
and thank you for taking my question I
noticed I know that out at Mount
Rushmore a lot of the the stones have
come loose and some of them fall down
and they've uh the federal government
has worked to to wire them back up and
to hold everything in place you know if
there's been any any uh suggestions or
work to perhaps re uh reconstruct the
old man and wire him back up
I I don't
I know it when it first happened
I do know that the the old man was wired
together for years at least prior to its
failure yeah so I I believe there's
somebody else
I can wait yeah thank you
other questions
all right thank you sir thank you David
Nielsen
good morning Representatives David
Nielsen I am the caretaker of the Old
Man of the Mountain
so uh
um my father was the first caretaker of
the Old Man of the Mountain Niels
Nielsen and uh my dad myself along with
my wife Deb
here for the old man from 1960 to when
he fell in 2003.
we undertook many many occasions to
secure the forehead Stone and secure the
mountain from slipping away and trying
to deter the natural effects of acid
rain to the Rock and things like that we
always knew that it would fall
we were just hoping that it wouldn't
fall in our lifetime
and the summer of 2002
Deb and I were successful at placing my
dad's ashes in the old man's left eye
and
it was his wish
to remain with the old man and in fact
he does today
The Old Man of the Mountain was
responsible for tens of millions of
dollars of Tourism and economic value to
the state of New Hampshire
going back at least to 1805 and perhaps
even to 1604.
The Old Man of the Mountain is on signs
we have the old man of the mountains on
t-shirts The Old Man of the Mountain is
still a very vibrant
part of the economy of the State of New
Hampshire
it's not the memory of the old man is
not only important to my family but is
important to the history of the state of
New Hampshire
I wholeheartedly encourage you to
embrace
on this this bill and there are several
efforts afoot to do something special on
May 3rd and I think this would be a
A fitting tribute if there's any
questions I'd be glad to answer them
thank you very much are there questions
representative shuitt
thank you madam chair
um good morning good morning I believe
that you served on an official
Commission
to look at possibilities shortly after
the old man fell that's correct can you
tell us what they I know they considered
things such as reconstruction can you
fill the committee in on on what the
determinations were it actually
literally started the day the old man
fell on Governor Benson myself and Dick
Hamilton were in a helicopter and after
we viewed away the old man no longer was
governor Benson turned to me and said so
now what do we do
uh we created a commission that studied
viabilities of replacing the old man on
the mountain creating a new old man at
the bottom and
[Music]
what eventually became known as profile
plaza where you can go and and
memorialize the old man
there are several things there you can
look at one of the profilers and you can
see the old man on the mountain again
there's some there's one of the original
turnbuckles that was on top of the
mountain
and eventually
what it came down to is or my family we
believe the Old Man was created
naturally survived naturally and died
naturally and should be left that way
however we left it up to the general
public of the State of New Hampshire we
advertised what was your opinion what do
you think we should do to memorialize
the old man
and in fact someone did in fact say
let's rebuild the old man
and in two thousand four dollars the
estimate to do that was three million
dollars
I can probably add a zero to that in
today's dollars
and I can tell you that
being as Frugal as the state of New
Hampshire is there will be no way that
they would spend three Thirty million
dollars to rebuild the old man
um I think that the what we did was a
very tasteful
um and adequate
remembrance of the old man it's a great
place to go Deb and I go there every
year on the University of the fall of
the old man
uh pair respects
and I encourage you to do the same
um
representative O'Brien and then Simon
thank you uh Madam uh chair uh just a
brief comment and that is you know I
come from Nashua I took my kids up there
when we used to go camping up north and
going through the Notch and always
stopped to visit with the old man I
would like at this time to officially
thank you and your family for keeping
such a historical thing that represented
our state it's on our license plates and
everything else like that so uh Kudos
too bad nature took over it does happen
but thank you for the uh being the
Watchman of the old men thank you you're
very welcome sir thank you okay
representative Simon thank you madam
chair
um coming from Littleton obviously
um that's up in my neck of the woods and
I know for myself and a lot of people
turning the corner on profile Lake and
seeing the old man was coming home you
know it was just there was something
different about it so
um I appreciate that as well and from
that perspective I want to thank you for
all the time that you've spent
um taking care of of that Monument
um growing up always wondered here you
are so I can ask you how often did you
go up there
we would usually go up
um in the spring and after the snow had
gone and see how he wintered and prior
to 1980 we hiked up and down the old man
the mountain and that would take us
seven or eight days to complete the that
Year's work whatever that was starting
in 1980 we used a helicopter service jbi
helicopters the first few years the time
was donated to the state of New
Hampshire
that allowed us to go to shrink that to
two or three days a year
you usually went in July in July toward
the end of July the weather is better
then
whatever work we had to do for the year
we I gave him a shave and a haircut and
we weighed them and measured him every
year
things like that and then frequently in
the fall during foliage season debit I
would take a hike to the old man just to
put him to bed for the winter
thank you welcome back
representative Dolan
thank you madam chair I I guess I agree
with you that 30 million dollars is a
pretty
pretty severe price tag and that I would
not be supportive of that if they were
tax dollars but
I would be optimistic
that given
the nature of the tourist attraction and
the sentimental value of New Hampshire
that that we couldn't Cobble together or
somebody couldn't Cobble together
uh private donations that would could
equal that amount uh so I guess I I
wouldn't be so quick to say that it's
not it's not viable and we shouldn't do
it but I I think it's I think it's uh
something that ought to be kept on the
table in terms of reconstruction I think
I could speak to that one of the ideas
that they had the Legacy fund had
um to memorialize the old man was to
actually create a series of monoliths
along the pathway down to the lake and
when you stood in a particular place
looking along on the line of monoliths
you'd be able to see the old man proper
size and shape some of these rocks were
in the vicinity 200 tons
they were actually coordinating in Berry
Vermont and they were would have been
taken from Barry Vermont to the state of
New Hampshire and placed in this
particular pattern that was the idea the
approximate cost of that job was two and
a half million dollars
the Legacy fund could not raise enough
money
to get enough interest in that to raise
more money
so that's where they went about selling
the paver stones and
um were able to raise enough money to
complete the profile Plaza
along the way we had a disagreement
about how funds should be raised and I
stepped away from the Legacy fund and I
don't have anything to do with them now
I don't know what plans they have on the
table now but I do know that they have
some plans for May 3rd this year to
memorialize the 20th anniversary when
they were talking about
rebuilding an old man on the mountain
they spoke to the artist and the Name
Escapes me that created the Tree of Life
at Disney in Florida
he professed that he had the technology
to then at that time recreate the old
man and put him back on the mountain by
drilling into the Rock and creating a
fiberglass type
picture and we would not be able to tell
the difference from his idea and what
the old man really was
he had no idea who I was I raised my
hand and just answered question session
and I asked him who are you going to get
to drill the holes in the rock
he said well I was really thinking that
the people that took care of the old man
would drill the holes in a rock
he said I'm here to tell you I'm not
going to do that
and that was the end of it
so
I can't say that it would never happen
thank you Professor man triputi
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question or a comment and I do
remember taking my kids there sure and
uh doing you know it was a very special
visit to be at the mountain uh but my
question is I mean I see the sentiment
there's a lot of historic uh peace to it
it was part of New Hampshire history
and he guarded New Hampshire folks
spiritually
is there any effort or has that historic
peace being included in the New
Hampshire history curriculum
since you know my kids learned in school
that there's a family that curates and
watches over and you know they would do
the field trip in fourth grade when they
did the local
has there been updated with the
I'm not familiar that there is any
updated curriculum to that I do know
that years ago children in fourth grade
studied New Hampshire history and they
and I lectured approximately 50
different elementary schools every year
about the old man in the history of the
old man and things like that
um so I'm not I haven't done an
elementary school in a number of years I
still lecture to General Civic groups
but
um
I'm assuming
that they still study New Hampshire
history and that the old man would be
part of it yes
you were part just a comment that you
were part of you came to Bicentennial
School and my kids studied and they were
very excited thank you yeah thank you
representative Smith
thank you madam chair first a question
of the chair I'm here as a substitute
for the executive session does that
um entitle me to participate in um in
the hearing rather than the executive
session
the executive session will follow the
hearing if you have a question that you
think will Enlighten the rest of the
committee or Enlighten yourself please
um you you spoke quite eloquently about
the natural formation of
um the man in the mountain and then your
work and our former sergeant-at-arms
work to
um
uh to maintain the natural structure
I'm a little
befuddled about why
when we think of ourselves as the
granite state
we would even consider
um creating
man-made replica
thinking that somehow that would be the
equivalent of
the granite formation that was there do
you have any comment on that I would um
I would agree you know I don't believe
that carving something
an artist carving something is the same
as nature carving that that's why I said
our family firmly believed that the Old
Man was created naturally
survived naturally yes we did some
things to make him age longer okay we
hope gracefully and that he passed away
you know naturally in the middle of the
night nobody got to see it I didn't have
to watch it on the six o'clock news like
the falling of the Twin Towers
you know I'm very happy
knowing that
I do not think that
um
creating an artist creating another Old
Man of the Mountain would be the same
there's an excess of 25 different
thank you madam chair
um I was up there a number of times over
the years I'm not from New Hampshire
originally but I've been here for about
40 years I was up there I have such a
vivid recollection I don't think that
I'm imagining it but was it not possible
to uh to go up and and see the the
formation from relatively close you
couldn't get out there where it was
um but uh but
the profile of course was what we're all
familiar with but from any other angle
and from the location itself it was
absolutely unremarkable the way the
stone stuck out and so forth and so on
from any other angle there was nothing
to see except just rock sticking out and
only the profile gave the impression of
the Stone Face
so I I think I agree with you that any
attempt to reconstruct something
certainly it could not be made of stone
uh because it would have the same
ultimate uh you know end that the old
man had and putting something up there
um to create the profile would be
um I think uh along the lines of your
your thought that was naturally created
uh to inspire us all and it fell even in
spite of all the cables and wires that
you guys put up there to keep it in
place uh and
recreating it would not be a possibility
right you could when the old man was
there actually hike to the old man and
go out and sit on top of his head like
when when we worked there it was open to
the public there were hiking trails to
and from it we generally didn't
encourage people to do that because
people by their very nature would
vandalize The Old Man and that was part
of the work that we had to fix every
year was you know somebody covering
their initials or a heart with initials
in it and things like that on the on the
old man that we had to repair every year
but you could you still can today
um if you if you're very very courageous
sure do you have a question
thank you madam chair
um having known
your your pop who was actually a member
of the House of Representatives
um and you and your wife literally uh
risking life and limb to go over the
edge to do repair work do you feel if
there were a reconstruction
that it would be worthwhile for someone
to do that kind of dangerous work to
ensure that it stayed there I'm assuming
the stability of a reconstruction would
Memorial Day if you don't mind I mean we
can we can chat with these people
afterwards but uh
is there any questions about that's
somewhat related to the bill
all right thank you very much for your
testimony
good morning my name is Robert white and
I'm a landscape architect from
Portsmouth and Intervale and I I believe
I may be able to be helpful in a variety
of these questions but I realize that
we're also a little off the topic of
your bill today but what I would say is
background to myself and why I'm here is
for a period of at least six years I was
the consultant involved in advising the
old man to the mountain Legacy Fund in
the development of the memorial Concepts
um taking them working with all of the
committee members with a design
competition for the memorial and so I
had a deep understanding of the of
the process that went through and the
direction where that was going I think
it's fair to say that we went to the
doors of four different governors
and have and and until the Legacy fund
decided to lay down the effort to
complete the memorial
uh we walked away empty-handed without
leadership from the state of New
Hampshire to recognize what is probably
New Hampshire's most important symbol
so there's a certain amount of
frustration with that we would love to
uh have been successful in the private
fundraising campaign to do that the uh
the profile Plaza that you see out there
was basically one part of a recognition
of a three-part original idea for the
memorialization of The Old Man and the
experience
three three parts of experience that
were really seen as sort of a an
archetypal New Hampshire experience
so but I'm here because there's a uh
you're faced with a decision and I would
I'm here to advocate for it because I
think there's really one basic principle
that we need from you and that is
recognition
and so I'm gonna uh so while I'm a
landscape architect I'm also a trail
Builder
I have spent 12 weeks when I was in
college in high school in college
working on Franconia Ridge the old man
is a friend I'm not I'm not as directly
related to the old man is the nielsens
but I do have some skin in the game on
this
um but uh so
um what I want just what I wanted to say
in regards to this is that people in our
state are anxious
for the memory of the old man to be
acknowledged
this designation of the um of the Old
Man of the Mountain day on the day that
he fell I use a trail building analogy
to it when we used to this when we
started building rock steps up Mount
Lafayette and across Franconia Ridge and
off all the trails in the White
Mountains of which I've been involved
for almost 50 years
what we learned was that you needed to
lay before you started steps and you
started climbing you had to lay a
foundation and that Foundation was a
stone at the very bottom of a staircase
it could be at the bottom of five steps
or 500 steps and that that stone was the
foundation upon which everything else
was possible and so the way I see it is
the metaphor for this gesture of the
recognition is that's the foundation
step to which we will have the
opportunity with leadership with funding
with the the the uh you know the state
and local and basically every resident
of this state to participate as well as
visitors
to then have a foundation upon which
other important recognitions of the Old
Man of the Mountain can be rekindled and
be brought back to a proper
consideration so that we can actually do
something about this memorialization the
history of memorials in our country is
many of them took a very long time one
of my college professors was the
designer of the FDR Memorial
in Washington DC it took 50 years before
between the design
approval of that and the actual
execution of that Memorial I would say
it's worth the wait the old man is worth
the wait also because he certainly was
there for hundreds if if not thousands
of years so we can wait to get the right
answer but we need the foundation and
this is a very important recognition of
that so I would like to close I wish
that I had the opportunity to have one
of my colleagues with me but in
recognition of
of in in 2019
celebrated the 200th anniversary of the
Crawford path as the oldest continuously
maintained footpath in America over in
Crawford notch in night in 1919 to 2019
was the 100th anniversary of the
Appalachian Mountain Club trail crew of
which I had the pleasure to serve on for
five years and I'm still involved as an
alumni at Camp Dodge as a part of that
recognition I commissioned odds Bodkin
who was New Hampshire's probably most
famous Storyteller to tell a story of
what became 200 years of Trail building
in the White Mountains The Old Man of
the Mountain features prominently but
I'd just like to take about three more
minutes to play you the very end of this
recording so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to pull it up on my computer here
and I'm I've been instructed to point
the microphone at the speakers
so we'll see if this wonderfully
low-tech solution
to a high-tech uh
silver and the reasons after surfing the
wind above this year's robot
cross Franconia Notch and land on the
old man of the mountains
the slab the rear part
all that's left of the famous old faith
upon The Ridge
at least a part of him that was made of
Rock
[Music]
despite Decades of epoxy and iron bars
cement cables and hand cranks each
straining to keep all 7 200 tons of him
up there he finally joins his brothers
and sisters one night on the palace
the delicately on his two block
thousands of years
just enough of which it finally rotted
the cowling clay
the upper lipid nose go to suddenly with
nothing holding them up the eyebrow and
and seven thousand tons of rock quite
famous rock quite symbolic and storied
rock tumbles down to the screen and
the Thunder
going up and down Franconia notch
that's at least 30 40 seconds
look up there honey
nobody does anymore nobody here is
involved at night nobody even knows he's
if you imagine
[Music]
saw the Paleo people arise 12 000 years
he didn't blame them for Never Going Up
To those Frosty Gods own eye knowing
that the cold could kill
and he never blamed Abel and even either
living in their time and are completely
ignoring all that dotting their moose
skins and going up there anyway
[Music]
and thanks to the trail cruise for 200
years bikers have been doing so ever
since
maybe there's a little less ax work
these days a little more stone work
a few Tools of Change
but always there's work to do up on
America's lost the invention
once winter has blasted the white Hills
then blowdowns block the paths
here's SWAT report summers in the trails
and the whites
[Music]
spend too much time in the mountains
we'll Wanderer
Spirit but just listen
ing
[Music]
thank you
are there any questions thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
okay seeing none I will close the public
hearing
all right um we'll go into executive
session representative true you have a
motion
uh thank you madam Madam chair
um I move uh host Bill 96 and expedient
to legislate
ah okay
all right move by representative true
second about representative Lucas do you
wish to speak to your motion thank you
madam chair
um
I'm not not denying anything about the
Old Man of the Mountain you certainly a
solid part of New Hampshire history
um but as far as the bill
uh like like many other bills that have
come before this committee uh looking to
uh to memorialize in statute
um
I don't feel that
that the statute is the proper place uh
placement for a memorialization of the
Old Man of the Mountain
um
has been we heard today that it's the
this this year is the 20th anniversary
certainly A fitting A fitting time for
uh for any concerned groups or people
who want to get together to celebrate
the Old Man of the Mountain and at that
time they could certainly go to the
governor and and with with a big uh
whoop to do uh have the governor
proclaim the 20th anniversary something
very important
um
that is uh certainly up to uh up to up
to the individual citizens of the state
if they want to do something like that
to go ahead and do it but but not to not
to put something into uh into statue I
think it it just gets lost we've got lot
I think there's 28 uh
various issues that have memorialized in
statute that no one remembers if we want
to remember the Old Man of the Mountain
we should do that with uh within with
groups uh getting together to to do such
such thing thank you madam chair there's
something like us do we should speak to
your second I just uh agree with what he
said on that
any representative shewitt
thank you madam chair
um having served on this committee I
believe this is my fifth term uh I
generally have hold that ideal that was
mentioned that we don't like naming days
however in this particular case
I feel this is such an iconic part of
our state
um
identity that I am going to oppose itl I
would hope that we could have it
preserved and recognized in statute and
I think that would give whoever's still
around in 50 or 100 years the impetus to
encourage whoever the governor is at
that time to continue the recognition
for the old man thank you okay anyone
else
as much as I respect representative
shuitt's position
and um
I'm pragmatic
I view representation
from different aspects
and I see the old man on the mountain
you know license plates I see the old
man mountain in a lot of things
I know we have statues
in our state for those people that we
commemorate
and I think that those are more valuable
um
we were as passionate about
the
representation of other elements of our
state as we are as a state towards the
Old Man of the Mountain
so I will be supporting the itl motion
and I
uh I'm just looking at it from that
point of view on this that I think that
when we think about what New Hampshire
is known for our beautiful beaches the
uh the foliage in the fall
ski resorts that we make use of in the
wintertime
the Capitol building that we're sitting
in now the the drive up the highway the
gold
the gold Dome is Iconic but but none of
them none of those things compare with
the New Hampshire's old man in the
mountain it is in my view step waist way
above any of those and it would be a
shame that we if we hadn't if we don't
have a a way to
to uh
to observe recognition of that in my
view work to recreate it but that's not
on the table now so I'll be voting
against the Ito
Ley
thank you madam chair
I want to thank the folks for coming
today I uh have a place up in Bethlehem
I just I've
taken a position over the years on
naming days because as representative
true said the numbers that are currently
in statute are somewhere around 26 28.
days listed
this calls on the governor to Proclaim
annually and I don't know of any
governor
yet or haven't heard of a governor yet
that wouldn't Proclaim that day
and
I'm torn because my position we've had
some great causes come before this
committee that I have said no to and I
think it does a disservice to those
other organizations that have come
before us in doing so
to pass this one or to vote for this
I mean I could tell you almost the exact
spot I was the day this fell when I got
the phone call in the morning bright and
early in the morning
um
and it was I get to receive the phone
call while I was fishing on Lake
Winnipesaukee that morning
and I received a phone call from many of
you know the individual Terry path had
called me as soon as he heard from State
Police that had fallen
so I could tell you almost exactly where
but for the reason stated I mean I think
it's more important to continue the
efforts
at the site in doing what you're doing
on the anniversaries and reaching out
and having the governor do it than just
putting it into statute where it is if
you asked anybody to name all 26 days
that are in statute right now I don't
I think it's more important to stay out
in the Forefront out in the focus and
continue to do the job that you just did
here today bring it all to our attention
as to what happened
so
I just wanted to let everybody know the
reason if I don't support this why I'm
not thank you
representative Simon
thank you very much Madam chair
um I share with all of us the common
revered memory of the old man and I have
very high I hold in very high regard the
prime sponsor of this legislation and
those others who have joined him
And yet when I read the bill
I see nothing that requires legislative
action we are not being asked to create
an entity to solve this problem
of how we continue to memorialize the
old man we are not being asked thank
goodness to spend money because of
course we wouldn't
um we are not being asked to do anything
legislatively
all we're being asked to do is to put in
an RSA that no one will ever read
and that to me
does a disservice
to the incredible importance that the
old man holds in this state there is
indication here that the governor should
do something
but is it appropriate for the
legislature to direct the governor to
take not a legislative action but an
executive action
I think that there's much that could and
should be done
to continue to maintain the importance
of the Old Man and the mountain in this
in this state I think this legislation
diminishes that
um by burying
this language in the rsas rather than
encouraging making sure that the
governor does what is clearly in his
power to do and continuing to support in
in public the actions of those who care
so much about
maintaining its memories so
um
with unbelievable respect for the
sponsors and for the Fallen structure I
thank you madam chair and I would like
to thank the members of the committee
for their comments
um
people have spoken very eloquently and
very passionately about that and as a
member of the North Country I appreciate
that representative Smith could not have
spoken more eloquently and although we
sometimes find ourselves on opposite
ends of of a debate we're in agreement
on this one the old man on the mountain
is different for people of the North
country than I think it is for other
people in this state for us it's home
for us it was a symbol of kind of our
Northern rugged Independence and we had
a great affinity for it as a part of our
community and I remember coming into my
place of business the day after that it
had fallen and it was a day just spent
with people coming in and out sharing
memories talking about it
and so there is I have no lack of of
love for the old man on the mountain
quite the opposite
um as a member of the North country
um but I agree the bill as well
intentioned as it is uh does do a
disservice uh to to the to the monument
um if it did have a fiscal note saying
we're going to spend money and do
something as typefisted as we can be
sometimes I would actually support that
um if it was going to bring something to
the people of the North Country
um I would support that
um
but this will just get buried and and
piggybacking on representative goalie's
comments
um being able to you know to say 26 of
them is nearly impossible I would say
almost nobody can mention one of them
and get it correct
um so I just don't think this is the
proper Avenue although I do appreciate
and would continue to support efforts to
push
actual celebration actual
memorialization of the old man so thank
thank you madam chair I'm
just a couple of uh things in terms of
yes he's a old man is an icon is a
historic uh symbol for our state
and this only does the day of
uh the old man disappearing
um you know and it's important to we
don't know the beginning so we only know
the ending and so with that I would like
to say there's nothing to say how do we
keep the memory alive the history alive
to incorporate into the curriculum in
our kids the future generation that
never saw
the old man actually existing but knows
that it existed to have those kind of
thing is more meaningful than just um
acknowledging the end of a icon
so
but it's a good path I do respect that
and um
I will see how it goes and
and thank you
anyone
all right the motion is itl by
representative true and the Clifton call
foreign
yes
all right good afternoon everyone
um
yes
as a special treat this afternoon after
we finish our our executive sessions the
oplc will be presenting an overview of
they're at their intentions on
uh the license deletions and
consolidations in House Bill 2 and
you're all welcome to stay for it
uh we'll see what it does
and meanwhile I'm opening the hearing on
House Bill 428 and I call Representative
Shapiro
sorry I forgot about 12 30 speakers
that's okay
it was
thank you madam chair and thank you
colleagues for the record I am Joe
Shapiro representing Cheshire 16 Ward 2
and keen and nine surrounding small
towns
so um as you will quickly see there's a
a large amendment to this bill but so
I'm going to start off with the
having served on last year's committee
to study and make recommendations
relative to licensure and Mental Health
Professions I'm here to introduce
one of the several bills coming out of
that committee's work House Bill 428 was
requested by and written with the
collaboration of the board of mental
health and oplc
the underlying Bill does three things
well let me first this bill is about
conditional licenses and since um
I am a licensed social worker and never
heard of conditional licenses maybe I
should start off by explaining what a
conditional license is
um
so a conditional license was evidently
passed into law in 2021.
um
edits RSA 330a and a conditional license
for social workers licensed Mental
Health Counselors I think for pastoral
counselors as well or or marriage and
family counselors is a licensed
before someone gets their independent
clinical license so for an example
somebody goes to school and gets a
masters in social work
um they are unlicensed but they get a
job and a Community Mental Health Center
so that at the Community Mental Health
Center they are providing Services they
are under contract a supervision
contract
um and they are headed for licensure
independent licensure in approximately
two years but in the meantime they're
providing services
so this bill that was passed in 2021
creates a conditional license for people
who are yet to be independently licensed
but are already practicing in some
capacity
um in the case of a social worker right
at a school they'd be
um
practicing under the auspices of the
mental health center probably the
medical director
but it could also be under this
supervision of a a licensed social
worker
so
it adds relevant language under the
licensed independent Mental Health
Counselors and marriage and family
therapists so when the when the bill was
first passed and then it was written at
the statute all of these CL all of these
conditional licenses Were Somehow added
to the section
um on social work as opposed to the
other section so this really just cleans
up where the language goes it doesn't
change
um it doesn't change the concept of a
conditional license it doesn't really
change anything it just puts the
it requires oplc to set fees for these
conditional licenses and third it makes
clear that those conditional licenses
are subject to the jurisdiction of the
board
and you should please note that these
conditional licenses have not yet been
implemented I think they're still in the
process of having rules written so they
haven't been implemented but it really
is a problem that
um
prior to these conditional licenses
people would be practicing under
somebody else's license
and if there was a complaint about them
they don't come under the jurisdiction
of the board so with conditional
so you should have before you
um
and I don't have one before me but um
you should have um before you Amendment
excuse me sir you said three things
yes put the language in the right place
it allows them to
um create a fee these people on a
jurisdiction of the board and the fee of
course how could I forget the fee okay
so with the addition of amendment 0916
this bill
will also will enter New Hampshire into
a social work licensure compact a much
awaited opportunity requiring adoption
by minimum of seven states
implementation of the compact will
increase access to Mental Health
Services
promote portability and address
Workforce shortages by eliminating the
need for licenses in multiple States
reduce burdensome and duplicative
duplicative requirements associated with
holding licenses in multiple States
maintain consumer protection
and support military families who move
frequently whether they be patients of a
social worker or whether one of the
family members be a social work
practitioner
coming from a family of social workers
my dad was a social worker my brother is
a social worker my daughter is a social
worker and I am a social worker it is an
honor to bring this bill to you today I
think it will be a step forward toward
meeting the very significant challenge
of responding to the mental health needs
so that's what I've got
um and I'm willing to take questions
although I think there are people here
who are um
will be better able to answer the
that makes sense
thank you madam chair
um so what happens if the compact does
not adopted
well you said
you said that
the bill underlying bill is you know it
does what it does but that in your
remarks about the compact you stressed
some of the advantages of it
um but what happens if the con if the
compact doesn't get adopted
obviously with the short it won't do the
things it would do but uh
does the underlying Bill survive
um yes that's up to us this isn't the
compact is an addition not a
substitution yep can I can I speak to
that I I think the chair is absolutely
correct if the um amendment is not
adopted then the other part of the bill
will go forward
um but in terms of it um the amendment
being adopted and US joining the compact
um the compact will not go into effect
until seven states
um join I think if we don't join I I
assume and someone will be able to say
that there'll be an opportunity to join
later after it goes into effect the
advantage of joining these compacts
initially is that when you're an early
adopter you get to help in the
implementation process including writing
various rules and regulations for how
I have one question uh representative
Shapiro are you aware that this language
of House Bill 428 is actually included
um that was suggested to me when I
walked in but I was not aware of that oh
thank you okay other questions
representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair uh just two
questions uh
the reason the compact is coming is an
amendment to this bill is that when
our committee to study this in the fall
on what's Happening the language wasn't
ready when the time came to put in lsrs
the language wasn't ready so this is hot
off the press and that's why it's coming
in as an amendment would it be fair to
say that no states have yet joined the
compact
I don't know that for sure but I would
assume that that could be correct thank
you I would agree represent Broda thank
you
um so representative Shapiro this bill
came out of a work committee that you
and I were on correct and so the the
base Bill your original bill
was written what part of the
um mental health boards I can't recall
exactly I do remember talking about this
but I don't recall exactly when this
came into play and perhaps that would be
useful to the committee on understanding
how it is that we got to this bill from
the work that was done in that committee
thank you for the question
um I don't really think the specifics of
this bill got discussed during that
committee but
um
during that committee Dr Goodnow came
and an attorney from
oplc came and participated and talked
about a lot of the issues that we talked
about and because we had met there
um
Dr good now who was the chair of the
board of board of mental health
approached me after that to say we have
a problem
um we have this language about
conditional licenses and it's all all
the wording is in the wrong places so
this was by virtue of the fact that we
met those people at that committee not
something that was discussed at that
committee
okay
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question representative so you
said the on even though the underlying
bill and the provisional licensing has
not been implemented it was passed the
bill passed last term but not being
yes and I assume it came through this
committee because it didn't come through
Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs where I served so I assume it
came through this committee
and I would I would just like to say one
other thing just in terms of you know my
view of the importance of having
um enhanced portability of licenses
um
since serving over the last three terms
I've been approached by a number of
people in my community who were trying
to hire mental health practitioners who
were having a a difficult time doing so
and this was
frequently one of their complaints and
um
and
just two nights ago I um went to dinner
at someone's house which I've almost
haven't done in probably three years and
I met somebody who had just recently
moved to Keene
um I so we introduced ourselves they
said they were dental hygienists um um I
know this doesn't
um deal with dental hygienists
um and and and I said oh that's great
because we just passed a dental benefit
for Medicaid and um
and she said that's great but I'm
working in Brattleboro she said when I
tried to get a license from Nevada where
she had moved from
I got a license in three days from
Vermont
um but she didn't go into details and I
didn't solicit this information but
evidently it's a long-standing complaint
that it's difficult to come with a
license from another state and be able
to get a license handily here and join
thank you
foreign
thank you chair Maguire and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Lynn Stanley I am a social worker and
the executive director of the National
Association of Social Workers New
Hampshire chapter
we are in support of the underlying Bill
and delighted to be here today uh with
the amendment of The Social Work compact
as representative Shapiro said this is
hot off the presses it was
finally ready uh February 27th there are
a number of states where
racing towards the the Finish Line to to
be part of the first seven New Hampshire
has a long history and of adopting
interstate compacts the psychologists
have had their compact for years now the
Mental Health Counselors had their
compact
approved last year and we are hoping
that we will be able to be uh as social
workers included in interstate compacts
uh
as representative Shapiro said one of
the reasons why we're
pushing in hard to try and get to be uh
front of the line is because some of the
major decisions will be made by the
states that are initial adopters and
actors of the compact we think that we
have a lot to offer and and want to be
part of that decision-making process
within the compact language there are
three different licensure tiers New
Hampshire qualifies for two of them that
would be the LSW and the licsw New
Hampshire does not have an lmsw or
licensed masters social worker we have a
licensed social worker which is a
bachelor's level social worker somebody
who has their BSW from an accredited
program
that has not been put into action yet
but it has been put into statute that
there is that licensure tier so our bsws
from Plymouth State and from UNH would
be eligible for this interstate compact
uh more commonly and uh in greater
numbers is the licsw licensed
independent clinical social worker
there are a little over 1700 licensed
independent clinical social workers who
are right now active in the state of New
Hampshire
uh they the all of the finer details of
how this will work will come after the
rules are written by the commission the
interstate compact commission but it is
anticipated that somebody who has their
licsw in New Hampshire would be able to
apply for their interstate compact
license it is New Hampshire that would
decide whether or not an allies whether
somebody qualifies for their licsw and
for the interstate compact license
any complaints that are made it is
or somebody who is licensed originally
in New Hampshire the complaints are
handled by New Hampshire
even if the complaint does come from one
of the member states where the client
might be I will also point out that the
the interstate compact is based on where
a person resides not where they work
there are some social workers who live
in New Hampshire but work in
Massachusetts so they have their their
license in Massachusetts for this they
would need to have their license
in New Hampshire because it is based on
there are so many benefits to the
portability that an interstate compact
allows especially in New England where
in talking with my uh colleagues from
the other states and I am my colleague
for Vermont I'm also the executive
director for the Vermont chapter it is
anticipated within the next year or two
all of the New England states will be
will be able to be a part of this will
have it enacted in their states
uh I talk with social workers all the
time who have three licenses right they
live on the Seacoast they have their
license in New Hampshire they have their
license in Maine they have their license
in Massachusetts it is expensive and one
needs to maintain like Okay Main qual
requires this for re-licensure New
Hampshire requires this Massachusetts
requires something else with this you
would have one set of criteria New
Hampshire's criteria if you live in New
Hampshire to follow and then that way
you are still able to see clients in all
the other states that have adopted the
compact
this allows for when somebody's client
goes on vacation moves away uh the the
social worker themselves is out of state
as long as they're in a member State
they are able to con to continue seeing
their client without the fear of uh
weighing out is this an emergency would
I be able if there's a problem uh do I
run the risk of losing my license
this eliminates that military families
are
the reason why the Department of Defense
issues the grants to write these
compacts is because military spouses are
some of the most underemployed people in
the country because they move from state
to state and it takes a while to get a
new license
so military families would be absolutely
uh
benefiting for the social workers who
are part of military families moving
and another issue that always comes up
for for social workers is when their
client is a college student and the
class the college student goes out of
state and can they continue to see that
student and the answer right now is no
unless you are licensed in the state
where your client is you cannot continue
to see them
this will eliminate that issue and
provide continuity of care for our
clients so I am happy to answer any
questions that you might have director
Courtney is also here she might be able
to answer some of these questions a
little better than I can
um but I do hope that you will adopt
this amendment to House Bill 428. thank
Gerhard and then goalie
thank you madam chair can you give me an
exam a concrete example of one of the
special privileges we have in changing
the rules if we were part of the first
seven
uh if
the vast majority of of the compact
language is about what the commission
will do the commission is going to set
up the rules they're going to set up the
database they're going to set up
everything uh in order to make it work
and so it is every member state gets a
representative on the commission but
it's those it's those first adopters
that will be at the table when a lot of
thank you madam chair and I just first
I'll follow up on that question because
as more States come in cannot those
rules and regulations be changed as the
states come forward and want to change
the initial rules and the setup if they
yes but once the once the database is
selected in the the criteria is selected
they're not
from my reading of it they'll be meeting
once a year
so yes rules could change down the road
but my
my uh
guess is that they would not be it would
be uh
a collaborative decision because oh
there's something that we didn't take
into consideration and we need to change
oh
so the initial setup of the rules would
probably be mostly standardized going
forward not something that
New Hampshire would be looking
specifically for but it would be what
all states initially involved
are looking to set forward
it it could be I'm gonna defer to
director Courtney as she was part of the
so if we start allowing states to pick
where people want to set up their shop
could that allow someone to
operate out of a state that has
a lower licensing fee
than where they currently are situated
and also maybe Target a state where
rates are a little higher and
yes but they'd have to move there so
um if right now we already have
a multitude of licensed social workers
who are working in Massachusetts because
the rates are higher and Massachusetts
is really close by
that's a personal decision that
everybody needs to make I'm not sure how
much State shopping there would be for
who where you can get a license
easier or less expensively the
at their at their roots are very
standardized accredited MSW program two
years clinical supervision exam and the
aswb exam
that's true across the board some states
have different oh you need to take this
course or this jurisprudence exam but at
at its core uh the requirements for your
licsw are extremely similar
does that answer your question
folks leaving the state for better
opportunities or folks
who become licensed here
taking up clients in other states
because it's more profitable than taking
up the clients here in New Hampshire
if you if you already are a part of this
if you have your social work compact
license in New Hampshire and you decide
to move to Montana because and Montana
is a
a member State you then need to get your
sorry I'm just trying to like connect to
the Dots here uh so if that's the choice
people would be seeing you're you're
thinking via Telehealth and picking up a
client
s
it would depend on where the insurance
probably not Montana
okay other questions representation
thank you madam chair
so what kind of a shortfall are we
looking at in the state of New Hampshire
right at the moment in terms of people
shortfall in terms of number of people
who are looking for uh social workers
and cannot find them or agencies that
are looking for social workers that
can't hire them
that would be the among the groups that
certainly would be interested in uh
having more people available to come
with the compact permit that
yes because you could you could move
here and you if you already have your
interstate compact license then you're
already good to go and would be able to
start seeing seeing clients while behind
the scenes you're doing the paperwork to
update your home state
uh so and that's one of the things that
I hear about is from both agencies and
from social workers I'd like I I have a
job
but it's based it's conditional on my
having a license and so if there's that
delay a month three months six months
and getting my license that prevents
that social worker from working and that
agency from having the personal there
thank you madam chair so uh but I I'm
not getting an answer and I realize you
can't give us a specific answer but how
much of a shortfall is there in New
Hampshire right now for social workers
and the categories that you've mentioned
the license social worker or the
and bachelor's level you not sure how
sure
they have the data for that what I have
is anecdotally hearing that Community
Mental Health Centers there's there's
months long wait to get into to be able
to be seen
um and I am hearing from social workers
that they have no more
if they set up a waiting list and most
social workers don't set if they're in
private or small group practice they
can't even set up a waiting list because
the numbers are too great that people
are
knocking on their doors and there's just
no room that certainly is an indicator
of that there's a there's definitely a
Workforce shortage thank you I wish that
I had specific numbers and data but I do
not
oh actually no represent Broder you are
a sponsor of this bill
[Laughter]
can't I can't question you may testify
it's okay I am too
um so go ahead representative thank you
so
one of the concerns that I have when I
hear anybody talking about
um agreements that are going to
regardless of what it is that are going
to make Workforce to build Workforce
availability increase
pretty much
all over so where these how is this
going to in theory
it looks like it would work
but in in reality will it
and what maybe this is where
um this Courtney can be more helpful
what examples do we have in New
Hampshire
where compacts have actually done this
that last question thank you for the
question that last question is
definitely for uh
for director Courtney
I think one of the ways that it affects
Workforce and availability of clinicians
is if if you have a client
who who has moved
either to New Hampshire or from New
Hampshire if the if the social worker
can continue seeing them then that
client doesn't need to find another
social worker
right if uh if the social worker's
client is a college student and now
they're in Vermont they're going to UVM
and the social worker in New Hampshire
isn't licensed in Vermont that
that college student who's the client
doesn't need to find a new social worker
they can continue seeing their their
provider same with if somebody from
Vermont goes to UNH now we don't need to
find a new clinician in New Hampshire
because they can continue seeing their
social worker in Vermont so uh
so that's just one small way that we're
managing the workforce that we do have
in a better in a better way and if we
have uh
if it is less cumbersome for social
workers to be licensed in
a number of states especially the social
workers who are on a border like on the
border of Massachusetts Vermont or or
they are they are better able to do what
they need to do and not pay for multiple
licenses and so that they can can
a good question yes representative thank
you madam chair
when it comes to Renewal licensing if
you have
different state licenses continuing ad
and you know those can be different and
will the compact eliminate that and have
one set of continuing ad so there's one
fee one set that you don't have to
straddle multiple yes thank you for the
question if you are if New Hampshire is
your home state you are licensed in New
Hampshire you need to follow New
Hampshire's rules for relicensure but
you you don't need to also follow
Maine's and Massachusetts where you
previously might have also had to have
been licensed or currently are licensed
thank you representative goalie
thank you madam chair I just wanna
question one more point because we talk
about border states and it'd be nice to
work across the line state lines and
this and that and then
I just don't understand why we can't get
reciprocity among states we have to join
a compact and the reason I'm asking is
because when you get into compact
language
and I've brought this up numerous times
in other compacts we've had before this
committee and this is where I really
have troubles
is on page 11
so everybody can look on line 27
where the compact is allowed to hire
employees
electoral Point officers fixed
compensation to find duties Grant such
individuals appropriate authority to
carry out the purpose of the Compact and
establish a commission's Personnel
policies programs and such and such
assess and collect fees
and then the important part is
accept any and all appropriate gifts
donations grants money other sources of
revenue equipment supplies and lease
purchase retain own hold improve any
property real personal mixed or any
other I mean this gives a compact
exorbitant amount of power and what they
can do
and there's no check that I know of on
how much money they can spend and what
the fees could be coming back to the
state of New Hampshire
and if you could just expound a little
bit about that and when you look at up
on line 23 purchase and maintain
insurance and bonds
I mean
I'm looking at what the cost could be to
run this compact and I don't understand
why bordering states can't work out
some sort of package where they
themselves can do something without
getting into something this intrinsical
thank you for the question I'm going to
anyone else
question of the chair since I I don't
see the director here at the moment
okay
hiding behind doing okay yes yes that
happens okay representative thank you
madam chair can I you did say that the
the Department of Defense funds these
compacts the Department of Defense uh
gives the grants to write to pull
together the people like a council on
state governments as The Association of
Social Work boards nasw National
Association of Social Workers they get
they distribute the grants to pull the
people together to write the the
language interesting all right thank you
thank you
all right I think we're we've come to a
point where we need to hear from
director Courtney
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee for the record Lindsay
Courtney executive director New
Hampshire office of professional Ace
insurance certification
oplc is in fully support both of the
bill but also as the as of the proposed
amendment I had the um pleasure of
representing New Hampshire on the
document drafting team that worked with
other states and other stakeholders to
draft the language of the compact so I'm
able to answer any technical questions
that you may have
wanted to know I know that this has been
noted previously but this the the
compacts that you see today and you will
likely see in the future
um have been funded by the Department of
Defense and the reason for that is uh
DOD has viewed it uh vital to have
um increased portability for military
spouses something that oplc obviously
fully supports and so we urge your
support of a compact and and this
particular field
we are members of other compacts in fact
I think with respect to occupational
licensing compacts the only two compacts
that we are not members of are the APRN
Compact and the EMS licensure compact we
previously were part of the EMS compact
that's not under oplc that's uh
Department of Safety and I understand
the legislature chose to
um to get out of that compact the reason
why we are not part of the APRN compact
is because that compact provides that
aprns have to be supervised by a
physician and we recognize independent
practitioner Authority in this state and
therefore choose not to join that
compact but with respect to all other
available compacts New Hampshire has
readily joined and the reason for this
is because it promotes greater
portability of licensure
um
this compact is unique however the
language is is very similar in certain
respects but there are two points that
make this compact unique first it's the
first compact since nursing that has
adopted the multi-state licensure
compact model
and what that means is you get your
license and your state of domicile
and you do not need to seek permission
to practice elsewhere and we see this a
lot with nursing for example Florida is
a compact state if you are if you reside
in Florida and you have a Florida
compact license you accept a travel
assignment to New Hampshire you come up
here for a couple of months so you don't
change your residence we don't need to
hear from you we don't need any
additional fees
you just go do your job and you go home
if you choose to change your Residence
at that point we will switch your
compact to a nursing to a New Hampshire
nursing Compact and I have to say
particularly during the pandemic but
also subsequent to that with extreme
Workforce shortages we are relying
significantly on Travelers and so the
nursing compact in particular has been
very vital to the state's ability to
function
um so this compact is modeled after that
yes representative
um you said that this is the first that
is modeled that has this feature or is
the nursing compact already had that and
you're copying it it's the first after
nursing ah thank you yeah nursing I
think was one of the first if not the
first occupational licensing Compact and
no other compact after that has has used
this model but the document drafting
team felt that uh one of the sole
purposes was to promote greater
portability and um that the multi-state
licensure model was the best mechanism
to do that
um the other reason why this one is
unique and it's more of you know I'm a
legal nerd
um it's where you have to get licenses
based on your domicile not based on your
residence uh it's a legal
um
definition but we've run into issues
with people having multiple resonances
and not being able to determine where
they actually need their license and so
um I myself pushed very strongly for for
use of the term domicile and that is why
um
this compact in particular is unique
it's also unique because it has three
categories of licensure most compacts do
not most compacts focus on one category
of licensure and so it made this compact
particularly challenging to draft which
is why it took so long for the language
to be released because there were a lot
of issues that the document drafting
team had to work through in order to
make sure that it was practical
I do want to note that I think the most
relevant section in terms of determining
what the qualifications are is on page
five section four that's basically where
you're going to find what a social
worker has to do in order to obtain a
compact license and section B an
applicant for a clinical category
multi-state license has to fulfill the
following requirements pass a competency
requirement which in this case we
anticipate to be the exam that our our
licensees already take the aswb exam
and then they have to be eligible for a
licensure in New Hampshire they have to
complete a master's degree in social
work from an accredited program we
already require that and then they have
to fulfill a practice requirement
um equal to a minimum of 3 000 hours and
we already require that there was a lot
of discussion amongst the document
drafting team and the technical Advisory
Group about the 300 000 hours
requirement some states require more
hours some states require fewer hours
the majority of States I believe require
3 000 hours and we settled on 3 000
hours as a compromise
fortunately New Hampshire already
requires 3 000 hours so
um so there would be no need to change
the way we process licenses in New
Hampshire in order to
um in order to meet the compact
requirements
couple of other things I wanted to note
before I answer any questions is that
the whole the compact is a contract
between the states and so each state is
required to adopt the specific language
in the compact it's a mirror image the
state can at any time choose to get out
of the Compact and we've seen that New
Hampshire has taken that opportunity
with respect to the EMS Compact and so
if the compact is not running smoothly
if for whatever reason policy in this
and the state changes we feel the need
to get out the legislature can certainly
do that
but at this point given the workforce
shortages I think it's vital that we do
what we can to promote greater
portability and I just want to bring up
our licensure statistics from covid-19
pandemic when we modified our licensure
requirements to allow us to issue
licenses to individuals in other states
we saw a 44 increase in the number of
licensed social workers
who were licensed in New Hampshire so
there's clearly a need and and this
would just be another Avenue for us to
provide increased access to mental
health services so with that I'm happy
to answer any questions could you enter
representative Goldie's question about
the authorities of the commission yes
certainly I think that's pretty standard
I mean I share your concerns
representative goalie in practice I've
never seen it be problematic
um
are we charged the same fee for license
in nursing that we which for compacts
and for non-compacts for single state
licenses I can pull up the data in terms
of what we pay ncsbn
um but I think it's under ten thousand
dollars a year which from our
perspective is pretty minimal
so we've never observed any issues with
compact commissions being extremely
large and just getting out of control
but again I would suggest that that the
one way that we can manage that would be
to obviously
thank you madam chair
um so
I'm sure you heard representative
goalie's question on relevant to page 11
especially lines 13 to the bottom of the
page
those of us who have been on this
committee for a while and on the
subcommittee as well
ordinarily I asked whether we're going
to go to subcommittee but I don't see
where they have the time to do that but
representative Schmidt my plan is to
retain this and work on it in
conjunction with the section we pulled
we're recommending to be pulled out of
house bill too because that's the
um
there's a strong overlap okay so that's
that's great news because trying to
decide this all in a short time frame
that we have for the rest we wouldn't do
that for you well
so this language at the bottom of page
11 is a language it's very very familiar
to those of us who've been on the
subcommittee previously and it's caused
the problem before because it looks like
it opens the door to a lot of
acquisition of stuff especially stuff of
value and the possibility of abuse or
running wild or whatever so can you
speak to that particular issue certainly
and what one thing I would note is in
order for a compact to be valid this
language cannot change so the you know
the committee could not make any changes
otherwise we couldn't participate in the
compact it's an all or nothing that's
how the compact works but with respect
to the language I I I completely
understand and appreciate the concern
because it does appear to be extremely
broad that said I do think the
commission needs that Authority and I'll
give you the example with nursing every
compact has to have a database system
and nursing we call it nurses and every
compact member has access to that and so
what happens is all licensed RNs for
example are in the nurses database and
so we can verify as a licensure board
the status of that person's license
whether it's a multi-state whether
they've had any discipline we can also
send we are required under the terms of
the compact to notify other states
member states that a person has is in
the middle of being investigated for
significant action we are required to
send notifications and we call those
speed memos and so for example if if we
received a speed memo and we have there
have been instances where somebody is
working in our state they're here on a
compact license that was issued let's
say by Florida
we can Institute disciplinary
proceedings against their privilege to
practice on our state based on that
information so that database and all of
that information sharing requires
support both from a Personnel standpoint
and
um you know just database management it
just requires support so unfortunately I
think that language is necessary in
order to make it happen it does seem
really broad but it's it's vital to
making sure that that information
sharing can work
thank you so is it not the case that
this language in spite of the fact that
it sounds pretty scary is it not pretty
is it not quite typical and how many of
the compacts that we are currently
involved in quite a number according to
your earlier testimony is this language
not in those compacts already
I I'd have to compare every statute but
I would say this language or something
comparable must be in every compact
because every compact has to stand up a
data system
I wouldn't recommend New Hampshire
joining compacts if we didn't have the
capacity to share information readily
available because that could put the
public at risk
thank you thank you representative
blackis
thank you um
so I understand that reciprocity won't
do everything the compact would but uh
one of the arguments for the compact we
heard was it was taking a very long time
to for people to get licensed when they
moved to New Hampshire I know there's a
prior bill that went through this
committee and whatever is in hp2
and assuming one or both of those go
into law would that solve at least some
portion of this issue
yeah I think certainly
um I think it was House Bill 594 if I'm
not mistaken I think would greatly
assist with portability issues
um
I think one of the benefits and this is
why
the document team and I have to say
myself and the representative from Texas
really pushed hard for the multi-state
model
um is we push for the multi-state model
so that the practitioner doesn't have to
seek out you know 40 something or 50
something or 50 licenses if they choose
to practice in every jurisdiction so
that would just be an additional barrier
for the practitioner additionally I
would say that I will I would not be
surprised if our surrounding states
adopt this and so what happens is if we
become the only Oasis that's not part of
the compact
we may we may experience even greater
shortfalls of mental health Workforce
shortages as a result well
okay so
um if let's say this were to pass as
well as uh the other bill I mentioned as
I'm assuming there's no conflict there
and the reciprocity bill would then
allow
uh Reciprocity for states that don't at
least initially join the compact is that
correct yes that's correct
representative
okay first on gold
thank you madam chair and thank you for
the worker shortfall is an issue we hear
about we hear about it everywhere not
just with social workers beyond that
we're hearing a great deal about the
um struggles the mental health system in
New Hampshire is having
and I I would assume that's happening
all across the country
are there things in this compact that
are going to benefit
the efforts we're all making and intend
to make and we'll continue to make and
we'll push really really really really
really really really really really hard
to make
beyond the the Staffing shortages the
problems recruiting workers I'm assuming
is something that's going to ebb and
flow but are there things that you see
in here that are going to help us with
fixes to the mental health system
no not particularly I think that the New
Hampshire is going to have we have to
have a plan for Workforce and I think
part of that plan is attracting people
from other states and it and the
attraction can't be that it's it's easy
to get licensed here people should want
to move to New Hampshire because it's a
wonderful place to work and live that's
why I choose to stay I am a transplant I
usually don't admit that
um but I think then the next question is
if I want to move to New Hampshire if
I'm thinking about New Hampshire or
Vermont you know where can I work and I
will say hands down that Vermont can get
you issued a license much faster and we
lose people for that so I think ease of
licensure is a is a necessary
um it's something that we need to do for
those people that are looking to move
here we're not going to solve the
workforce issue with
um with licensure but I think we can
assist in removing those barriers
through greater portability that the
compact could provide
follow up
thank you I acknowledge the problems
with the workforce my question is do you
see things in this compact that are
going to help provision of service for
clients in New Hampshire I think that
the yeah certainly I think it could
ensure continuity of care I think what
we saw with covid-19 for example is that
we have a lot of people who
um who live in New Hampshire and who for
example go to Vermont for services and
then when those providers move to a
Telehealth platform those Vermont
practitioners Need a New Hampshire
license or when college students go
somewhere else then all of a sudden you
know the the provider needs to get a New
Hampshire license and and some providers
are willing to do that but I've had
others clients contact me saying I'll
pay for the license I don't want to lose
my therapist what my therapist doesn't
think it's at worth for just one client
to go through the licensure process so I
think for you know as more States join
the Compact and I have no reason to
think that they won't
um I I think that it will encourage
um continuity of care for those people
foreign
compacts in the past
can you
um
give us an estimate
on the
availability increase in Workforce as a
result of that compact is it five
percent to the ten percent is it
measurable is it you know I mean that's
the whole purpose of doing this right so
I would think that that would be one of
the metrics that we're monitoring I'd
have to say that I don't believe that
data is available nursing in particular
we wouldn't know
um because we don't know who's here
working on a compact that is the compact
model
um
for the other compacts I don't think
we've had a significant time utilizing
those compacts in order to adequately
measure that psychology we just recently
joined but
um actually I think we joined in 2019
but it's only recently that they got uh
the compact up and running mental health
is not up and running yet I don't think
speaker OT or Audiology are or if or if
they are they haven't
um we haven't started to issue compact
license under the compact so I don't
think that we have that data available
with our current challenges with respect
to data and also because of the the
compacts most of the compacts we have
just recently joined
represent rolling thank you madam chair
so if
someone in New Hampshire is part of a
compact
decides they want to go down and do six
months in Florida
working
a complaint comes out of Florida on that
individual
it goes to the home state license or
um it would be required to go to both so
assuming that the person was still
domiciled in New Hampshire New Hampshire
Reta is the only state that would retain
the authority to completely revoke the
license for example other states could
revoke that person's privilege to
practice in that particular state but
let's say Florida's decision to revoke
the privilege of to practice couldn't
impact the privilege to practice in
other compact States but New Hampshire
as the compact issuing state would have
full authority over that license and we
would receive that through that database
system and obviously take appropriate
action follow-up follow-up
so in order to revoke a license from
something that was done wrong in another
state
a hearing would have to be held
who's going to pay for the cost or the
follow-up from
someone in Florida to come testify or do
whatever needs to be done to have a
proper hearing
yeah I think we typically in those cases
it's not uncommon for us now to have
hearings remotely
um and so we typically
do offer the ability for individuals to
thank you madam chair this is a quick
one it should be easy regarding domicile
can you just help me out with the
difference between that and so is what
what is the legal term of where I vote
is it where I domicile
that's representative true
thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question
um did I hear you say that the wording
in this amendment
is all to do with the Compact and it's
it can't be changed
correct because each state has to adopt
the same language in order to be it for
it to be considered a contract and
enforceable
follow up thank you madam chair again
thank you
I'm trying to I'm trying to figure out
how how a compact is going to uh solve
shortages and different fields so let's
say Massachusetts uh has uh their social
workers they're all working out straight
they don't have enough help and they're
all
stressed out
and New Hampshire has a shortage of
social workers and they're all working
out straight they're all stressed out
so how would somebody going from
New Hampshire
help anything
like working in Massachusetts
they're still
don't have enough people
yeah thank you for the question
representative uh there are certainly a
I mean we talk about this all the time
with um or I talk about it all the time
with my colleagues who are in similar
positions in other states and even
internationally there's just a huge
Workforce shortage
um so like I said earlier licensure is
not going to solve the workforce problem
um we need to rely on other mechanisms
to recruit people to want to live and
work here but I think that licensure
shouldn't be a barrier that makes
somebody choose to go let's say to a
different state Vermont Maine if they
are seeking to relocate up here and that
does happen quite frequently
particularly on the border of the states
and I want to also mention so one of the
famous compacts that we all participate
in is the driver's license compact
so
um it we are part of a compact regarding
driver's licenses so in order for you to
drive through Massachusetts you don't
need to go get a Massachusetts license
you can drive to California
um you only need one license and it's
not until you change your domicile that
you need to get a new license this
compact would work very very similar to
that
thank you
anyone else all right thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
all right seeing none I will close the
public hearing and representative Broder
I believe you have a motion
I do I wish to help retain House Bill
thank you Mr Speaker I do because
um the this committee has will be
requesting that the board of mental
health portion of the of House Bill 2 be
pulled out so that we can look at it and
entirely and include this and this bill
and possibly its amendment in that is uh
and I think an appropriate thing to do
for our committee
thank you I'd like to say the same thing
we've
we don't have the time for this because
today is our deadline so we are going to
retain it and work on it we might
um depending on how quickly things come
together we might try and pass it as
part of a Senate bill this this spring
otherwise we'll work on it over the
summer and have something ready for the
house in January
if if this is just coming off the
printers to the other states now I don't
think that's going to be much of a delay
representative Gould
thank you madam chair I just want to say
that I'm really looking forward to all
of the bundle with the house bill 2 in
the mental health issues and I've
already started looking at that and I've
I did read these amendments and the
proposal for the compact
um ahead of the hearing thank you all
for your testimony I really look forward
to seeing this move ahead for New
Hampshire we have a crisis and we can
fix it
okay anyone else have a comment question
okay in that case the motion is to
retain House Bill 428 and the clerk can
call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative santoso yes
representative true
yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes
yeah clerk votes yes representative
groda
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative banjo putty yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yeah
and the chair yes
fine I understand that okay so we will
twenty representative Dolan had stepped
okay
okay all right
and I call the sponsor representative
Gould
thank you madam chair
House Bill 390 was originally drafted
two years ago it was drafted by a
bipartisan team from both sides of the
wall
to address some issues on uh that were
happening for the commission on Native
Affairs and I would direct the
committee's attention to an email that
representative Horrigan sent to us all
this morning where I thought he really
outlined kind of the history well and I
won't dig into that in the process of
um working with the state veterans
committee it became clear that uh as a
surprise to me honestly this quickly in
my uh term
that New Hampshire was ready to look at
recognition of Abenaki people in New
Hampshire and so
um I was very happy to have house bill
390 to be able to amend and a group of
us worked on this amendment and the goal
is to do a study so that this committee
will understand what is federal
recognition what is State recognition
what is the state's Authority which was
retained under RSA 14a part of the
commission to recognize State tribes and
um yeah I think that you're a pretty
bright group that's been my experience
and you'll learn a lot and I look
forward to the study and I'd be happy to
representative lacas
uh thank you so as I understand this is
a study committee that has to there's a
reporting date in November I believe
correct on is that at that point the uh
the study committee terminates correct
follow-up
follow-up yeah my only concern is um
is there really going to be enough time
to do what needs to be done to you know
you have to get all these people
together arrange meetings hopefully
they'll show up and come out with a
report in uh you know from the time this
bill goes into effect and then
so I feel really confident that over the
course of the summer that enough
education can happen in order to submit
a bill next fall that would be the next
step and I see this thing happening in
very small chunks with bills to define
the next step and that the legislature
will be defining the way to proceed
toward whether the state chooses to use
their statutory authority to recognize
I'd like to tell all the people that
want to take 10 minutes to tell us their
opposed to the bill
that we have all said we've pretty much
agreed that this bill as written is not
correct and should not go forward and
Our intention is to retain it and work
hopefully with your assistance so that
we will have something better for next
year so I hope you will all choose to be
very brief
foreign
off with my apology I didn't bring
enough copies there's several of you
that didn't get copies I'm very sorry
my name is Melinda Sims I am from
Belmont New Hampshire and I'm an abanaki
native and a veteran disabled veteran
I come I honorable chair and members of
the committee thank you so much for
having me here today I come to you today
as a concerned constituent with Native
American Heritage and a disabled veteran
HB 390 is a bill that essentially
rewrites the already established statute
that authorized the New Hampshire
Commission on Native American Affairs it
is not a simple bill it is a bill of
deception
The Honorable committee is being
deceived when hcr7 was recently tabled
and the school combined the bill with HB
390 and added a new amendment by
combining these uh yes one second
yeah your microphone
thank you Mr chair I'm not sure if the
witness knows but we do not tolerate in
in this committee personal attacks on
anyone either a member of the committee
or anyone else and so would it be
appropriate to guide her to talk about
the problems that she sees without
attacking an individual yes thank you
very much representative Smith we do our
best within the committee in the house
in general to make sure that we don't
attribute motive to somebody else's
actions
Smith thank you
um
let's see by combining these bills they
will achieve the intent of hcr7 and
erase the voice of most New Hampshire
indigenous people and put
the people from Vermont in the driver's
seat this trickery will also remove the
state's position of oversight and the
governor's ability to appoint commission
members it will eliminate the New
Hampshire Commission on Native American
Affairs we know this is to be true
because 17 years ago
the Vermont commission was dismantled at
that time and stacked with like-minded
people this is the very same thing
that's being proposed now with this HB
390 end amendment I understand the
committee is possibly bewildered by
what's going on here and are trying to
make sense of what this is about perhaps
you believe this is a family squabble I
assure you this is a personal power
struggle for control of the state being
waged by Vermont and against Paul and
Denise pulio
this is evident in Section 3 of HB 390
it states Chiefs and their parent child
sibling or spouse shall not be eligible
to serve in order to avoid a conflict of
interest the only people that this
caveat applies to are the chief speakers
of the Penacook that is now that is how
this bill is designed to remove their
voices this Clause would also make the
Penacook speakers ineligible for a seat
as affiliate faculty at UNH this bill is
an over attempt to silence them
are you aware that the Kawasaki band of
the Abenaki people already have an
inclusive tribal Community with two head
speakers Denise and Paul puleo
we do have a New Hampshire Commission on
Native American Affairs we have a tribal
consultation office at the University of
New Hampshire which is foundational in
establishing the UNH Native American in
indigenous studies program
and our head speakers have implemented a
501 c 3 organization to assist our
community
we are a thriving giving community that
does not have its hand out to the state
we are not in need of other entities for
us or changing what is already here
allowing this bill and amendment to pass
you are not helping the indigenous
Community or taxpayers of New Hampshire
instead you'll open Pandora's Box I hold
140 bills
brought before the Vermont legislature
by the nelhegan ban between 2009 and
2023. each bill costs the state money
lots of money and this is most likely to
happen to the New Hampshire taxpayers
too if this bill and amendment is passed
just like in Vermont miss school
just like in Vermont
they are attempting to take over the
already quite thriving New Hampshire
indigenous community and instead they
to get additional funding from New
Hampshire and be the only recipient of
federal funds or grants and glean from
if you give them an inch they'll take a
mile they'll not stop here they'll bleed
the state dry with never-ending bills
for monies and benefits like what's
already been done with to the state of
Vermont
our head speakers Paul and Denise puleo
don't cause problems for New Hampshire
they don't have their hand out to New
Hampshire they've actually solved
problems they have a great rapport with
the state of New Hampshire and through
numerous wonderful projects have
spearheaded that are spearheaded by our
speakers they provide Revenue to our
great state I respectfully urge you to
vote itl HB 390 and its Amendment
thank you for this time for listening
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions from the committee
I'm especially wondering uh because this
proposed study committee is made up of
people or entities
um unknown to most of us I'm sure uh or
not well understood so uh can you
comment or perhaps somebody else is
going to testify comment on lines uh 18
um
through
the bottom of the page 29 but the
constituent elements of the study
committee because I think uh
representative Smith just for
clarification are you talking about the
amendment or the bill itself talking
about the bill itself okay because
we haven't amended it yet
so
this is the amendment deals with the
study committee the underlying Bill
deals with the commission
perhaps Mike my question is not
appropriate anymore because again I
think this is
dangerous territory for this committee
representative crota
thing so I think that um
I want to reiterate what chairman
Maguire said I think the committee
recognizes the um disagreement within
the
uh
parties and this is not a place for the
legislature
and so
that's why we are going to be making a
recommendation to retain the bill which
is why we want to make sure that people
um we
start debating issues that at this point
honorable McGuire may I say something to
that
or no well I I don't know the rules I'm
sorry oh well the she's just saying that
we've gotten all your letters and emails
and we've read them and you've convinced
us this bill is not ready to go ahead so
we want to work on it with yours your
help
and retaining us will let us do that
is is that click do you wish to add
I just think that
um there's not Clarity I think that
again the the majority of you think it's
a family squabble and it's it's not that
uh we already have
a system in place in in New Hampshire
but somebody from the outside is coming
in to replace our system what's the
sense in that I don't understand this
as we said it needs a lot more work
including to find out why why if there
and
uh Mr Sims I take it you were
okay thank you
thank you
um honorables and chairperson
my name is Carlos Cardona I was born in
Aguadilla Puerto Rico also known as
imaco borinquen Osaka that means hello
greetings I see you
I have lived for the past 15 16 years in
Laconia New Hampshire
also territory of the Abenaki people
I've had the pleasure of being guided
and in my indigenous Journey as a Taino
by the great leaders as Denise polio
and and her husband
I have to say I am extremely concerned I
am also a member of the New Hampshire
native American Affairs commission
appointed by Governor Chris sununu
something rare actually as a Democrat
supported by a current governor that
sees the need for my people to be
represented here in New Hampshire in
the state felt the need to create this
commission that allows all indigenous
voices to be represented currently the
largest group of indigenous people in
the census today here in the state of
New Hampshire are Taino people also
known as boricua or you may know them as
Puerto Rican
17 000 of them this current bill
as it stands we'll get rid of the two
Taino voices in the commission and would
prohibit them from sitting there in that
Commission in the future the amendment
the amendment as I I'm hearing about it
is also concerning so as a member of My
Tribe and of course my people
representing here in the state of New
Hampshire I asked you to please just
kill this bill I also just passed a
letter from the chairwoman from our
commission
and out of respect for the chairwoman
and the wishes of Representative Margie
Marjorie Smith I will not be reading
some of the comments in this letter as
it does pertain to a specific state
representative on the committee but I
and I won't read them but I do want to
make sure that you guys know that there
are some extreme concerns for my
community and the lack of representation
that our people will have here in the
state of New Hampshire thank you we all
there's a strict literacy test for this
committee so we will read your your
letter and thank you for it I trust you
will and I don't want to take more of
your time but thank you if there's
anything I can do to help I'm happy to
assist we will be noticing the meetings
of the study of the retained Bill
committee and we you are more than
welcome to show up and participate thank
you thank you
okay
is it permissible for me to speak with
my mask on I have bronchitis we can hear
you okay I'll speak loudly thank you
very much for allowing me to speak I
appreciate that Madam chair and honored
committee members
I'm Kathleen Blake and I am the most
recent past chair of the New Hampshire
Commission on Native American Affairs
I am a woman of mixed Heritage with my
indigenous ancestors being members of
four Canadian First Nations wendat
Algonquin mcma and kichi sparini band of
the element Island anishinabio jibwa
I am not a member of an Abenaki tribe
and do not have Abenaki Heritage to my
knowledge
this bill is deeply flawed in the
amendment even more so
I have given you a handout also posted
on the portal and sent to each of you
via email explaining exactly why I
believe the bill is flawed
if you have been told that the
commission does not function as it
should and in compliance with state law
I suggest that you reach out to the
commission or to myself with any
questions you may have
it is always wise before committing to a
decision to be certain that all of the
facts that you have been given are
actually accurate and truthful
I believe this is your duty as elected
officials
House Bill 390 would remove every
current member of the commission and
replace it with appointments made by the
four Chiefs of the four four Vermont
recognized Abenaki bands
there are many problems with that
including that at least two of the bands
do not wish to interfere with New
Hampshire politics
were not consulted on this bill
nor was the New Hampshire commission
consulted on the bill
there is testimony on your portal from
both Chief Shirley hook who was one of
the one of the chiefs of the Florida
Vermont recognized tribes and chair and
Jennison of the commission
the proposed structure of this rewrite
places undue power in the hands of
Vermont tribes and disenfranchises all
New Hampshire bands in indigenous
citizens who are not members of them
Additionally the current commission
members who have appointed seats and who
have been extremely helpful through the
years would be removed as well
although the amendment was not passed
around to the audience I have seen a
copy of it and I wish to say that it is
not germane to the language in House
Bill 390 as presented
from reviewing your rules I learn a
committee of conference May either
change the title of any Bill submitted
to it nor add amendments that are not
germane to the subject matter of the
bill as originally submitted I'm sorry
excuse me yes for your information a
bill to a an amendment to take a bill
and change it into a study committee
generally related to the topic of the
bill has been declared to be always
germane okay thank you and we're nowhere
near the committee of Conference Point
okay thank you
um
study committee composition
has put forth in the uh document that I
reviewed is extremely concerning biased
is not inclusive of indigenous people in
New Hampshire
and frankly as a retired educator
it sounded to me like a group of uh
students getting together to write their
please be more
you you disagree with it fine you've
made your point you needn't insult
anybody
I was very honored to serve with the
commission for several years there are
many members of many tribal Nations
living in our state all of them find
welcome and support through the
commission
the current RSA supports us all
you have on the portal testimony against
this bill from people who are members or
descendants of at least four tribes
fennekook Red Lake Nation Mohawk kawasak
kowas tarantine mikma Cherokee Shawnee
Taino blackfeet Lac De Flambeau band of
lakes Superior Chippewa Indians and
Algonquin
you have testimony from the leaders of
the only three Abenaki tribes based in
New Hampshire all in opposition
one one of the people on the submitting
testimony called this bill an act of
paper genocide of indigenous peoples
that is that is accurate
one Vermont band does not speak for all
indigenous peoples who are citizens of
New Hampshire primarily they have a
voice
please I I understand you
plan to do a study committee
I am nevertheless asking you to please
itl this piece of legislation
thank you
yes
thank you madam chair just a quick
example what is
um
what is one example of something
significant that New Hampshire
commissioned on Native American Affairs
did I'm just curious like what is the
purview well just one example is fine
one example
um Native American remains and Grave
goods were held at a college in this
state
and not following proper procedures as
required by the nagpra regulations and
we were able to bring that to nagpra's
attention and those ancestral remains
will be placed where they belong all
right thank you
other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you madam chair
as a indigenous person that lives in New
Hampshire and also a veteran I also
oppose this bill
it's strongly worded against peoples
that are not recognized in this state
if recognition is the ultimate goal I
would strongly suggest a study group be
formed under the jurisdiction of this
commission to better acknowledge the
folks that live here still in this state
this bill cannot stand as it is
thank you
okay hello my name is Fawn Gaudet um
thank you state representatives for your
service and thank you honorable veterans
one thing as being a person of
indigenous is
um descent we all recognize that we all
are in relationship together on this
Earth and we are taking this opportunity
to open the doors for conversation and I
hope that what happens in this that we
can keep an ongoing discussion with all
of the many leaders of the state because
there are many groups in the state and
many leaders that you might not be aware
of
being a proud descendant of the
blackfeet nation and a New Hampshire
resident my mother was an enrolled
member of the blackfeet tribe my father
has indigenous blood as well I am proud
of my mixed Heritage
my experience with this federally
recognized tribe and I lived on the
Navajo reservation too so it's another
experience makes me aware of the many
issues proposed in this bill I feel that
you may have thought this was the road
to go down but in kindness with the hope
you with who you are I hope that you
would not condone such things in this
bill and the proposed amendment and I
would like to share that we heard about
the bill but the bill the amendment was
not posted
um
in a spirit of openness that was
um I feel it would have been better if
that was more open for us to see that in
more fair I want to say one thing the
commission is functioning just fine and
within the commission it's capable of
working on state
um recognition I think that
um another thing is proposability is
that you have the opportunity to um
it's it's opening the door for you
picking winners to losers and that does
damage to many indigenous peoples in the
state by taking where our voices on the
commission for people that are in the
state that live and people like me that
you know our tribe is not from the state
Assad it's me to share when one group is
willing to put itself above another
group this bill
um and let me be clear that no tribe
regardless of who they say they are has
a right to a govern another state group
or attempt to take control
um the bill wants to give the bill wants
to do so by giving control to Vermont in
groups in the New Hampshire Commission
of Native American Affairs if you pass
legislation with this you are
contributing to it I hope that you will
search in your hearts to say that this
is not a positive way to move forward
indeed it causes a great deal of harm to
indigenous peoples in New Hampshire and
as Kathleen stated there were Chiefs in
New Hampshire I mean Chiefs in Vermont
that oppose this bill there are other
group leaders in New Hampshire that
oppose this bill there is over I believe
130 something
indigenous peoples
um in this that oppose this and I hope
that you'll get a chance to read all of
their testimony
in addition the native commission has
places for other indigenous people that
would lose spots as the amendment and
the bill have stated I do not feel this
just I will want to be very clear that
one group or tribe does not speak for
all of the indigenous peoples in New
Hampshire I want to share this term with
compassion and openness this is a term
called paper genocide this proposed
legislation or races and Indigenous
voices of New Hampshire that reside here
in people that have come here
surely maintaining inclusivity is
important to the state of New Hampshire
and all of you
because we stand for truth and as
committee members and legislators you
have the power to make sure this does
I hope that you will itl this bill
and I hope that if you have any
questions that feel free to please ask
me and I hope that maybe in the future
that you can come come to the and
explore the rich culture and
contributions that indigenous peoples
bring to the state and have been working
on in this state
I don't see any so far thank you thank
you
foreign
Hello friends my name is Denise pulio
I'm the head female speaker and this is
Paul puglio head male speaker in Chief
of the kawasak band of the Penacook
adenaki people we come to you today from
Odana kunippi which translates to the
place of the narrowing of waters now
known as Alton New Hampshire
we typically go directly into
legislative testimony but I wanted to
take a moment to share who we are and
why we are here
some of you already know us as the
leaders of the Kawasaki and that we have
filed for federal acknowledgment and
were assigned petition number 151 by the
Bureau of Indian Affairs we have
appeared before this legislature for
many decades and both uplift and at
times to defend our indigenous community
we provide a multitude of indigenous
educational cultural and Social Services
to towns cities schools libraries
historical societies churches state and
federal agencies within indakina our
homelands of New Hampshire Vermont
Massachusetts and Maine
we have partnered with the University of
Massachusetts to create the Native
American and Indigenous studies minor
developed a Statewide University system
land stewardship statement we have
partnered on a multitude of projects
such as multi-year Federal and
Humanities grants like Carpe and
Indigenous climate research partnership
with the Arctic tribal communities in
Alaska and Sweden or with New Hampshire
sea Grant and the coastwise project
we have maintained a tribal consultation
office on UNH campus since 2019 and in
recognition of our work the UNH
sustainability Institute awarded us
their highest honors the Platinum
sustainability award for cune immunity
development in 2021
we have partnered with the U.S forestry
service on an indigenous forestry
maintenance and research project and
working with the University of Maine
Plymouth State and several other
Regional forestry groups on a variety of
environmental issues
we have co-founded indigenous New
Hampshire collaborative Collective and
many of you may have heard of inhcc an
interdisciplinary Community work group
that is decolonizing and uplifting
indigenous history and knowledge
throughout New Hampshire
inhcc has developed interactive maps as
well as creating and vetting indigenous
educational curriculum in collaboration
with UNH education we also provide a
multitude of resources that are
available for free at the indigenous
nh.com website
we are here to uplift our Greater
Community not just our tribe in our
society we are judged not by what wealth
we accumulate but by what wealth we can
give to others to go forward in a proper
way to maintain peace love joy
righteousness and to empower one another
in life
in 2010 we worked with Winchester
representative Dan Carr to create the
New Hampshire Commission on Native
American Affairs as a tribe we already
had a government-to-government
relationship with the state of New
Hampshire
so we specifically wrote the Bill that
honored our inclusive views and
developed commission requirements that
included the diversity of indigenous
people that are now residents of New
Hampshire
we are disappointed that in the last
election brought forward divisiveness
and this type of legislative drama this
is not a family issue we are not the
only tribe speaking out against this
legislation testimony has come in from
tribes all over the world speaking out
against hb390 and the amendment because
this legislation is not our way
we are here to defend our people the
greater indigenous Community residing
here in the state as well as the state
I have a question before I even give
testimony explicitly on the HP 390.
Madam chair
um when you talk about re retaining this
for study are you talking about the
original bill or the amendment both
all right then that opens my testimony
um
it's been alluded to that this was a
charge from the
to have a committee or some pathway for
State recognition and I want to point
out that it says very clearly in the
proposed amendment for abnaki tribes
that's already restricting the process
I'd like to also point out by because
the representative who presented this
and HCR 7 when they presented their uh
their resolution to recognize themselves
they're very clear that they started
with a preamble that talked about their
land claim from Northern Hampshire
it also said there was a lot of federal
things that they wanted to seek and
those Federal things all have physical
fiscal responsibility
I want you to be cautioned that if
you're retaining us for study and you're
looking at the amendment as well
there are several references to
non-governmental agencies that are going
to be Consultants
there's no prior informed consent from
any of these groups to participate and
this has been a problem with legislation
in the state where you
legislate in
faculty members from colleges and
institutions they have no legislative
responsibility to comply with any of
your study groups
what this really requires is
professionals to be involved and this
has a very significant fiscal note you
need experts you cannot come up with a
process unless you have experts like you
already heard in previous testimony
it's a slippery slope when we don't take
any money we deliberately will not pay
ourselves we roll all of our monies that
we get from federal and state grants and
other institutions back into projects as
a tribe we we try to uplift our
community and we spend all of the money
on projects not on wages
that's a very clear distinction from
other groups that look at this as a
revenue to pay their membership and
their leadership
I don't see how this has any clear
process to go forward the amendment
the people that are put here are not
qualified to do any recognition
especially deciding who's going to be on
the Commission in the beginning
you need some very skilled professionals
ethno historians
um G
certified National Certified genealogist
not just randomly saying somebody's a
genealogist you need some really serious
things which would be very similar to
what the federal government has that's
why we're following federal guidelines
for our own recognition we're not
seeking this we never asked you for this
we never asked to be here
any of the bills this year we're just
trying to defend us except for the
Columbus State though except for
Columbus Day I have to give that one up
but to keep on Integra integrating into
these conversations the museum the
cursed Indian museum or Dartmouth we
have found from the past that Dartmouth
will not even put a representative on
the commission of Native American
Affairs
so teachers and professes unobligated to
do their own work they're not obligated
to do your legislative work
so think about it seriously and think
about those those somewhat over 100
bills that were passed in Vermont in the
physical fiscal uh note that it
presented to uh Vermont citizens
forevermore
it was very clear in the testimony and
HCI 7 that excuse me we haven't heard
hcr7 that was an entirely different
committee well I I understand that I'm
gonna I'm gonna try to tie it in because
the representative did open the door
there was testimony that they were
seeking Federal money I don't know how
you can explain to your constituents
that you're going to allow another
outside State group
tie into and tap into monies that were
raised here from the federal system by
our residents to be transferred to
Vermont period this is a very you know
if you're going to be fiscal
conservatives why would you lead a path
for Vermont group to tap into New
Hampshire's state revenues period I mean
this is just common sense stuff I don't
you know all the rest of it it uh I
don't see any prior informed consent and
that's been a political issue there's no
indigenous consultation in this
amendment none and how we expected to
follow your proceedings as you do a
retained for study how are we supposed
to do that exactly
I mean when we're not allowed on to
participate and we're not allowed as a
Consulting party based on this as well I
mean so we have a lot of questions there
are a lot of issues with the amendment
and the initial bill within itself
um we think that the best move for this
committee would be to itl this bill to
have new legislation brought forth in
the fall the commission is already has
the tools needed to establish a
recognition process in the state the
tribes that are resident in the state
are already participating on that
commission so you would have indigenous
consultation
so our recommendation is to itl this
bill and we thank you for listening to
us today and we're welcome we welcome
any questions you may have
thank you
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair uh
since there's been reference to hcr7 I
sat in on that hearing uh and a question
I have is whether either
well especially the amendment which I
don't seem to have
whether the amendment in any way picks
up the subman's sum and substance of
hcr7 which has already been heard and
voted
I believe itl right correct so to the
degree that we are
getting a do-over in in the on the part
of thank you on the part of the uh uh on
the part of the the amendment I have I
think we need to look at that because
that's already been dealt with already
ideal'd uh and I believe it's all been
already been voted on in the house floor
um and uh so
I I I really want to bring that up to
the attention of the chair not not to
the testifiers because this is this is
so to the degree that HCR has already
been voted on already been ideal by the
house
yes on that is right something that we
cannot yes and that's that the amendment
is a do-over in any way
uh I'm not familiar enough with how hcr7
to say whether or not it is a do-over
that's that's exactly why I'm raising
the point we we are entering into
perilous Waters in my opinion uh on some
subject that we uh uh have little to no
expertise on thank you thank you thank
you may I follow up with one other
question one of the letters that we
received is uh from uh I I and I want to
have a quick uh ruling of the chair
whether that needs to be entered into
more than just submitted to us in
writing uh the letter I'm referring to
was sent by Anna Jenison
who might happen to know personally and
she is the chair yes she is the chair of
the New Hampshire Commission on Native
American Affairs so I think we really
need to
handle this more than just putting it
into our written file so I I was asking
Richard's ruling on that yes it will be
there and
we all have some light reading to do on
this stack of papers yes I also wanted
to thank representative Schmidt um the
amendment has still not been publicly
posted it so we have yet to find that
available online anywhere it is not an
it amendments are never online until
they have been voted by the committee
okay thank you did you get a paper copy
at least
um so I was able to secure with with
extreme difficulty a copy of the
amendment
um but it was but it has not been made
to the um I have shared that version you
know the copy that I've received as
widely as I could so um on some of the
portal comments you will notice that
some of them will refer to HB 390 and
Amendment
um that's because those individuals were
able to see the amendment because we
shared that with them where some
comments do not refer to the amendment
because it was not publicly made
until after a certain point in the
process
we highly recommend that you leave this
up to the Native American Commission in
the department of natural and cultural
resources there's a process already in
place the commissioner knows well what's
going on and we really this has been
this has been at the table at the
commission on how to deal with this
issue let the indigenous Community have
their own voice on this it is not a
legislative matter that you should step
into you should be approving whatever we
come up with and listen to what we'd
come up with don't try to put words in
our mouth and say you're speaking for us
this is not the way it's done
we're not
for you we
are addressing a New Hampshire statute
that establishes this commission and so
it is indeed within our purview to
change our statute not what the
commission does or reports or recommends
but the structure of it is in our
statutes and we take your advice we
agree what
we would take your advice on what who
should be included but if it's in our
law that's
that's our decision we agree um we just
think that maintaining the 15-seat
current commission outweighs replacing
it with a nine-seat commission with four
seats specifically I'm sorry five seats
specifically devoted to Vermont tribes
thank you we just want to maintain
inclusion within the state
okay all right no more questions you're
loud and clear all right thank you very
much uh please itl this way
hello my name is Rod Sims I'm speaking
for myself I like to really congratulate
you people on how nice you are to each
other I come from a 30-year background
in Union negotiations so they are not
very nice
um but
um
I do oppose this bill I don't want you
to put it in committee and waste time on
hashing things out when you're supposed
to come out with something that the
people here still do not want
people here have something that already
Works they don't want to mess with they
don't want Outsiders coming in here and
trying to tell them how to do things so
I think the bill should be itl'd and not
waste taxpayer money and your guys's
precious time and trying to come up with
something that's still not going to be
acceptable
um
the people who was involved in drawing
up the uh the amended version of this
um definitely do not have the peoples of
New Hampshire's best interest at heart
please don't impugn their motives they
may merely be mistaken or stupid okay
well
I mean you can't say that they're they
don't have the best interest in part
well I don't know their hearts I read
what was in the amendment and when we'd
go into contract negotiations everybody
would say things but what everybody had
to live by what was actually wrote down
on the contract so people can come in
and say one thing but you have to live
by what's agreed to in a contract so I
read what was in the wording not what
people were saying but what was actually
worded and the spirit of the people who
wrote that are not for the people here
in New Hampshire and they're definitely
against Paul and Denise pulio the
wording was specifically crafted to
eliminate them from any future
participation in anything going on in
New Hampshire so I don't see how those
people
no matter how much you talk to them are
going to change the way they feel about
that okay so thank you for that and
information so that's all I have to say
thank you
good afternoon
honorable committee members my name is
Daryl Peasley I'm from Kentucky New
Hampshire I've lived in New Hampshire
all my life
which is 62 years so far
I'm here to support the bill and the
amendment
and I understand you're going to retain
it study it
when you're studying
the bill please do your homework pull
the curtain back see who's pulling the
strings see how they're doing it
we keep I keep getting referred to as a
Vermont Indian
well I belong to a promise
recognized in the state of Vermont
this Ben peesley's in this state
since way before it was incorporated
the towns that the abunaki trails
project has been working in
very strong family ties
so it's not a bunch of Vermont Indians
that are trying to take anything over
we're trying to work for all abernaki
and I really hope that you can come up
with a process so that all Abenaki can
get the opportunity to be recognized if
that's what they so want
thank you
thank you very much
instructions uh no I don't see any
is there anybody else that wishes to
testify on House Bill 390
all right seeing none
uh
you we do it differently in the house
good afternoon my name is Reverend
Zachary Harmon I am a resident of
Goffstown and an Episcopal priest
serving here in the Episcopal Church of
New Hampshire thank you very much
honorable chair and honorable
representatives for your time I will be
very brief
and wish to speak uh in regards to HB
390 I believe that this seeks to remodel
the New Hampshire Commission on Native
American Affairs in a way that is not
helpful on the whole
um and creates a commission that is more
adversarial and less inclusive
how does HB 390 create an adversarial
New Hampshire Commission on Native
American Affairs it gives Vermont state
recognized abnaki tribes permanent seats
but it doesn't give permanent seats to
any other Native American groups with
connection to New Hampshire
it unbalances the commission and and I
believe hurts other Native American
groups in the state for instance it does
not include the chaosic band of the
Penacook Abenaki people who are well
known for their educational work in the
state I have worked a great deal with
them since 2018. I've worked doing
educational projects with churches and
in the community they have a great deal
to share and to teach
and Native American presence in
connection to New Hampshire I learn
every year increasingly is highly
complex
I I believe this bill as as written will
create more problems in the way that it
creates an adversarial structure of
haves and have-nots in terms of
commission representation
HB 390 is also less inclusive I believe
for three reasons one reason is that it
would create a significantly smaller
commission with fewer members and which
limits the voices and perspectives of
Native Americans in New Hampshire
a second reason is it is less inclusive
is that it is close to Native Americans
who do not have a direct connection to
one of the few named institutions in the
bill
a third reason that it is less inclusive
is that it creates a permanent majority
for the abnaki tribes recognized by the
state of Vermont
thus while other Native Americans are
included on the commission their voices
and perspectives will be a minority that
could easily be voted down
this bill takes the current Commission
on Native Affairs or Native American
Affairs which is relatively open and
inclusive and turns it into something
adversarial and less inclusive
for these reasons I would encourage you
to oppose the Bill thank you very much
thank you very much questions
thank you madam chair had you had
occasion to work with the New Hampshire
Commission on Native American Affairs I
have not worked directly with them but I
have used their website to help to
understand who to work with in the state
and if you could tell me was that
helpful constructive
um relevant or not yes I I found that to
be helpful uh because kind of as a
church leader in the um with the
Episcopal Church uh one of our religious
beliefs is that we should work out and
and try to restore the damage that's
been done with with colonialism and so
we're trying to understand who who are
the different Native American groups in
New Hampshire and who should we reach
out to uh to try and restore
relationships and so that that list
instead of Connections in that Network I
I found to be helpful thank you just one
more thing
um in your work uh with them although
it's not been directed have you um had
any reason to consider the possibility
that the structure the organization
should be changed in order for it to
better meet its stated goals and
objectives
I I haven't had any occasion to really
deeply wonder that I would say thank you
thank you very much
all right is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill 390
foreign
representative
you have a motion
yes
um I will make the motion and I motion
itl on House Bill 390.
by representative Schmidt okay do you
wish to speak to your motion I do so
when a committee retains a bill it is
with the idea that there is
um
a remedy for the bill
and that this the action that the
committee would make afterwards would be
recommended for further legislation or
not recommended for further legislation
that's as far as what a retain Bill does
well no
that's interim study oh sorry sorry
sorry this year we can actually amend
the bills we'll try to pass it
so let me take that back but my my
my feeling is that there's just too much
misunderstanding on the part of
on our part and and possibly the part on
the
and those involved
and I'm particularly saddened because we
as a committee get along very well and
we have quite opposing views
and I'm saddened that that isn't
happening and I'm particularly saddened
that any member that would testify
before us who had made disparaging
comments about a member of our own
committee that is hurtful to me
um
so I want to
recommend that we don't entertain this
bill and that we move on to something
else
if there is such a thing thank you
representative
I've already casually
indicated in my some of my questions
that I think that we are getting into
very dangerous Waters here
I I have a hard time imagining that this
committee
uh which has next to no experience is
going to be kind of sitting in judgment
about the commission on Native American
Affairs which already exists it's part
of our law it's a structure that has
existed for some time
by the testimony that we've heard it's a
functioning Commission
the letter from Ann Jenison which I have
not even had a chance to read but she is
opposing this bill
so the idea that we I'm going to call us
Caucasians and so forth are going to be
sitting in Judgment of of something
about which we know nothing but we're
going to have a we're going to take this
bill up and study it in a retained form
I
I I think this is extremely risky for us
to get into something I think that Paul
pulio Chief Paul pulio
um indicated already
that we are going to need expert
witnesses to be able to help us
make some kind of a judgment about
something we know nothing or next to
nothing about
I can't see that this is any I mean we
have expertise in this committee already
even the new people already have
expertise this is not an area in which I
think we should get involved
thank you thank you yes representative
Smith
Madam chair it is with the sadness that
I
want to speak
um of my distress at the statement made
by my very distinguished and experienced
colleague from Dover
I don't think the fact that the
committee is white or not
has anything at all to do with this
issue I don't think that in order to
address the problems of the poor one has
to be poor I don't think that in order
to address the problems of the sick you
have to be sick and I don't think in
order to address the problems of
the the indigenous peoples in this state
one has to be a member of a recognized
indigenous tribe what I do think is that
nothing has been presented to us so far
that would indicate that the statute
statutorily
created New Hampshire Commission on
Native American Affairs is not working
in the way that the legislature intended
it to work when it was created a number
of years ago and therefore it seems to
me that
we as legislators
ought to let the executive branch carry
out its responsibilities as they have
been directed to do and it is on that
basis not on the basis of our color our
religion our gender that I would say
that it isn't there is no reason that's
been presented to us today that would
indicate that we should
take action in support of this Bill
thank you
thank you very much representative
leckis thank you I'd like to strongly
second the comments of Representative
Smith the other thing is if we I tell it
that doesn't mean something
can't be done in the future in this
regard if
you know the effort goes into trying to
sort out what's the best thing to do if
the current commission isn't working as
it should
yes represent Gould
thank you madam chair perhaps I
misunderstood I I thought um the request
was to keep the testimony very brief
because we were going to retain the bill
uh we tried okay so
um
I'm just going to say that first of all
RSA 14
1A I believe it is the uh the end of the
current
law that authorizes the commission on
Native Affairs clearly states that the
commission on Native Affairs is
prohibited from recognizing Abenaki
tribes and that only the general court
has the authority to do that
so that was the reason for the study
committee is to help educate this group
not that they're experts in Native
Americans but you alone have the
statutory Authority Under federal law to
understand and know your rights and
responsibilities to recognize or not
Native American tribes in New Hampshire
and so that is what we would be studying
and that um the problems with the
commission historically had to do with
the number of people that they needed to
make a quorum and I know they still
struggle a little bit with that but I
know that they got a lot of appointments
made to the commission
the kind of statements that have been
made in this hearing aren't
um
aren't at all what we would be looking
at in a study would be looking at
federal law what is federal recognition
what is State recognition uh what is the
states the general Court's legal
authority to recognize State tribes and
however the states handled that and what
would be needed on the commission like
the legislative authority to do so so I
would strongly request that the
committee not itls bill but retain it so
that we can get educated and know only
you can do this nobody else can do this
only the general court can do this and
this is the committee that handles this
for the general court at this stage
thank you yes
representative Bill and
thank you madam chair I just want to say
that
um
I I think it's
should be obvious to us that
race
a race as a member of this committee
does not invalidate my opinion on this
legislation or anyone else's for that
matter
thank you yeah I I'd like to comment
that yes it may be our responsibility
to approve State recognition if some
were to be requested but I think that
absent a recommendation from a group
that is looking for State recognition or
a blanket policy from the commission on
Native American Affairs we shouldn't be
initiating the process for State
recognition
as other people have said you know we
have a commission that's working on it
if they choose to make a recommendation
to us that we need State recognition for
this that or the other group then we
will consider it but I don't think we
right anyone else representative Gerhard
I
I just don't see what the problem is
with the current commission I just was
never able to ascertain the issue so I
will also support the itl thank you
anyone else
represents like us yeah I'm in a bit of
a quandary I mean if if there is a
problem and there is a need for
some change
you know learning more about it and you
know figuring that out might make sense
you know retain might make sense for
that
but
um I mean maybe the best thing would be
for
you know some activity to occur to look
into this and come up with a specific
proposal
for us to consider in the future at this
anyway
yeah anyone else
all right thank you the motion is an
experience to legislate by
representative Broda and the clerk can
call the role
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas
yes
representative Bailey
no okay
sorry representative Santo Sasso yes
representative true true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
a bear yes representative Gerhard yes
clerk vote Jess representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuett yes representative manager Puti
yes
representative Davis
representative Fitzpatrick no
representative Gould
no
representative Smith yes
and the chair
yes
16 a
Renee
he came in after you gaveled yeah I was
here for the second to be perfectly
honest so I was a little tidy okay may I
make a comment
I just want to rep um issue a
representative ghoul that just because
we don't have a steady committee it
doesn't mean you can't form one
right she can she can certainly bring
other people in on this idea
um for the legislation on her own she
doesn't need us to form what she wants
to do
absolutely in any event the motion
passes and experience to legislate 16-3
and let
does anyone want to write a Minority
Report
no okay all right representative Broda a
I'm not making any more emotions today
by the way by the way committee yes all
right
um
fine in that case
hcr2 on condemning vandalism does anyone
I didn't quite get that Imam sure hcr2
condemning vandalism I just want to
remind representative Gould that was one
of the reasons why we waited until now
to
um
vote on these bills because she was
representative
police
your motion
thank you madam chair I'd like to make a
motion to itlhcr2
okay is there a second
do we should speak to your motion I
would like to speak to my motion thank
you madam chair the reason why I feel
that we should itl is
that the wording in the resolution is in
the past tense I don't think that this
bill is where it really needs to be to
pass it
all right thank you representative
Gerhart
I agree okay
anyone else representative Schmidt
I I think we need to
examine this
in terms of the actual language there's
one or two references to past tense of I
of actions or events that actually
okay some of the hate some of the hate
events or whatever did occur in the past
but otherwise it says is incumbent
stands United
Rejects
condemns
investigate calls on oh these are all
present tense these are our future
intents this is a misunderstanding of
the
question of the present tense or past
tense okay this is a mystery I'm sorry
representing but this is a misreading of
the your emotion stands but I will not
now the only thing I'll support the itl
um maybe not for that reason I haven't
looked through it again carefully as far
as the tents and all that but um I mean
the the legislature's already spoken
these kind of crimes are their crimes
um and that statement stands and I don't
I
worry about some of these terms that
have gotten more and more popular
including hate speech and things like
that it freedom of speech is just so
fundamental to the whole way our society
functions and that when we start saying
oh that's hateful that's not let's just
get everything out people say what they
got to say there'll be no they'll be
less violence because people now have
expressed themselves now as far as
vandalism no that's stupid it's already
against the law like Tony uh Mr
representative like I was just saying
but and also I get a little worried
about
the classification of group rights
individual rights I think is where we
need to focus if you assault somebody
it's assault on somebody
and that's the crime itself just because
you belong to this protected class I
just think it creates animosity and
unneeded undo burdens burdens on law
enforcement filling out a million
different reports it's just if somebody
commits a crime let's prosecute it and
keep it moving thank you anyone else
I'd like to say that I agree with
representative Gerhard and Lucas that
these items are primes already we can't
I don't see the point of us putting up a
resolution saying don't commit crimes we
we abhor people who would who commit
crimes
and I'm also concerned that it's a
concurrent resolution and it's
it's going to die if the Senate will not
accept it so I think it's
a well-meaning but rather feudal gesture
in my opinion well
represent baber
I think it's just a technical question I
know my motion
um my committee report is due today I
need it can I have it to you by 9 pm yes
assuming that you're responsible for it
but anyway so the motion is an
experience to legislate on hcr2 by
representative a bear and the clerk and
call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
yes representative Bailey yes
representative santoso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk vote
Jess representative groda yes
representative Schmidt
no
representative Ryan
yes
representative manjuapudi
no
representative Davis
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould no
representative Smith
no
and the chair
yes
13 yay 7-Day
that's
just 13-7 I don't think that's a consent
type of vote
um is there anyone who wishes to write a
okay when do you need it by manager and
meet um
was that Madam chair yes I'll be
habitual okay so representative Gould
okay
um HR 11
representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair I would like to
make the motion to ought to pass
on uh HR 11.
a second okay that's it
speaks an emotion please thank you madam
chair uh this is kind of old hat old
news for the city of Nashville we are a
welcoming Community I totally agree
sometimes we have things to come across
our desk whether you know
uh
do we want to support it or not you know
is it already codified into law or
something like that but the way I look
at House Bill uh excuse me HR 11.
resolution HR 11 is this is a branding
issue okay it should counter in a way be
almost like a no-brainer I think most of
us in our communities do welcome people
uh we appreciate the businesses that the
good people of Massachusetts like coming
from Nashua that do come up and spend
money at the you know the Pheasant Lane
Mall or other type of places those of us
who live farther up in the north
probably do appreciate the vacations
that come up these skiers and everything
else and if we think solely and strictly
just on the statement of branding why
not you know in other words that a whole
state should be a welcoming Community to
all come in you know you want them to
open up their wallet or make them feel
welcomed when they're doing so you know
so I'm going to urge you to use uh
please stand with me in support of our
resolution number 11. thank you thank
you professor
I so enjoyed that I don't dare add to it
Ah that's very respectful of you other
does anyone else have a comment
representative gerhardt thank you madam
chair I do think that we need I agree
with representative O'Brien I do think
we need to welcome people especially
those who are trying to spend money up
here but I think we do that via our laws
that make us the freest in the Northeast
it's well established that's why people
come up here's low taxes and everything
else and the liquor stores so I I'm not
so sure that this would really I mean is
somebody really going to be looking at a
vacation plan going Vermont New
Hampshire oh they're a welcoming
Community I just I don't I don't see
that going into the
the um
decision so I I just find this kind of
one of those feel-good things which
makes sense but I think the way you
really welcome people is you lift
everybody's boat up and there's more
businesses for them to come frequently
so I'd just say that thank you all right
anyone anyone else have a comment
representative true
thank you madam chair
I sort of feel like I should be saying
yes to OTP but there's a lot of me
that's screaming no
um
I am against
codifying days
into statute
um
so putting a month into statute I I
could be 30 or 31 times even more
against that
actually representative true this is not
put it into statute it's just a uh a
session law
which means it'll be impossible to find
in the future
that makes me feel a little bit better
thank you for that
um but but the idea that uh we we're
gonna say the state should urge small
businesses to do this
or do that or don't do this or don't do
that
whether you're welcoming or not uh I'm
against the uh
okay thank you
anyone else representative Aber
I'd like to Second representative true's
comments thank you okay
anyone else
representative Simon
thank you madam chair these are always
tricky ones to handle and I feel like we
handle these kinds of things a lot
obviously
um
I at least for myself welcoming
communities the concept of it is
something that I support very strongly
um but when we start getting into the
language of urging our constituents
um with you know with the authority that
we have even though yes this is a
resolution we frequently talk about
resolutions getting lost because they do
and they might not be seen very often
um it's difficult to qualify what
welcoming means because it's frequently
in the eye of the person receiving the
gesture and that can be very different
to different people and being able to
adequately come to a consensus on what
that might look like could be difficult
something that's welcoming to one person
can be offensive to another I find that
to be a difficult thing to balance
that's primarily the reason why I'm not
going to support the house resolution
although obviously I wasn't here this
morning but I did listen
um remotely and uh representative
mangaputi I appreciate you bringing it
forward and
um
and the concept of it I'm very much in
support of
anyone else represents
oh thank you I agree with uh what
representative Simon said in addition
um I'm just not comfortable doing things
that in effect have no they don't do
anything they don't have any real
consequential action like the other
special days I know this is a resolution
on a day but it's similar in that
respect
anyone else
not seeing anybody in that case the
motion is ought to pass by
representative O'Brien and the court
called the rule
representative Simon no Representative
no representative Bailey no
representative Samuel no representative
true no representative Dolan no
representative a bear no representative
Gerhard no
clerk votes no
representative yes
all right representative goalie
yes
representative shewitt yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes
and the chair
no
and we gotta vote 10 yay nine nay
ten
six seven eight nine
ten nay 98 yes thank you that's what I I
counted but uh the motion fails
representative Simon you have a motion
thank you madam chair I'll move itl on
HR 11.
that's Chris okay representative true
seconds
all right do you wish to speak to your
motion
no thank you I think we've discussed it
okay anyone else who wishes to say
something
okay the motion is an explained to
legislate on house resolution 11 and by
representative Simon and the clerk and
representative Simon yes
representative yes representative Bailey
yes representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerard yes clerk vote
Jess representative groda
no
representative goalie
representative shewitt
representative O'Brien I consisted no
representative mangaputi no
representative Davis no representative
Fitzpatrick no representative Gould no
representative Smith
and the chair
yes
okay the motion passes representative
Simon you'll committee report tonight
and is does someone wish to write a
Minority Report
yes one of us will do something so it
will be there tonight too yes if it's
not we're gonna have to draw us for us
ah okay thank you
well sorry I'd love to have your report
but unfortunately you're you're not a
member of the committee if you write it
if you send it to representative groder
she'll undoubtedly find someone who'll
be delighted to put their name on it I
can do that
okay so I that won't be considered
plagiarism or copying right
I need to know the name so yes all right
so representative a bear and
representative Gould owed me one on hcr2
representative
no representative Simon owes me one on
you owe me one on 390 yes and
um
and she has already submitted
representative already put that in
um
and uh fortnite 428 is retained thank
you all
um
I sorry about the lateness of the hour
but I promised director Courtney that we
would listen to her about the uh
licensing changes and house bill 2. so
if anyone is interested please stay if
you are if you have other other demands
okay yes Alex
yeah
step out for now and we'll I don't know
how long it will be but I suspect it
put a question mark if there's
um
we will if you once you send once
somebody sends one in we'll replace the
name
okay
yes
all right
um good afternoon I'm sorry it's so late
we
we ran into into some issues we weren't
expecting
it's not a problem representative I do
appreciate the time
um so good afternoon Madam chair members
of the committee I appreciate your time
um just for the record my name is Deanna
Juris I'm the governor's director of
appointments
um and I'm really just here to thank you
for your time
um for hearing the proposal today um
kind of in its comprehensive overview
um executive director Lindsey Courtney
knows this inside and out and she knows
the board's inside and out so really
um
I just want to say that I appreciate
your time even at the late hour and the
work that you guys have done at this
committee over the last I mean you spent
a lot of time on licensing boards but
over the last year I know you've spent a
lot of time looking at this licensure
reform making a lot of positive changes
um a lot of which makes some of the
stuff that the governor proposed
possible because of the structural
changes so you might view some of these
policy decisions differently than the
proposal um but I appreciate you
considering the whole picture so I'm
going to kick it off to the executive
director for the rest of the time but we
foreign
thank you madam chair members of the
committee um
again as dee mentioned I really
appreciate your time I know it's late in
the day and I promise to try to keep
this as brief as possible
um do you if you just want to hand these
out too yes I have a couple of handouts
that will go along with my
hopefully a brief presentation
um but I just wanted to start
um
by saying that this committee and really
the general Corps as a whole through
various statutes and other declarations
has made the decision the policy
decision that licensure really should
only be instituted to protect the public
that's the only legitimate reason for
licensure
um there are certainly other reasons why
we license individuals and we can't
resolve the insurance reimbursement
issue at present but the only true basis
for licensure is to protect the public
and to the extent that uh there are
other less restrictive means of
protecting the public this legislature
has chosen not to regulate in those
areas so I think the governor's proposal
is intended to be consistent with the
prior policy Declarations of the
legislature I think you've probably seen
the press release that that we issued
outlining what HB proposes to do
but in a nutshell it establishes
Universal licensure recognition it
transfers certain boards to the office
merges certain boards eliminates certain
license types and eliminates certain
boards
I know this committee has already
addressed a universal licensure
recognition in some form through House
Bill 594 which oplc certainly report
supports
I think there are some data that you
could find in our annual report to
support this
particularly during the experiment that
was the code 19 emergency pandemic and
the emergency licensure process we
observed an increase substantial
increase in the number of licensed
Healthcare professionals 22 000 we had
fewer than 10 complaints that we
received and we only had one reported
disciplinary action and so I think that
that those metrics really support the
idea that we can in the office safely
adjudicate licensure applications allow
individuals from out of state to come
into this our Workforce in an
expeditious time frame without harming
the public
um some of the boards that have come
before you recently to express certain
concerns
I just wanted to highlight some
statistics particularly or around the
mental health field
during the pandemic I have 36 percent of
latex we're practicing on an emergency
license alone uh 45 percent of Mental
Health Counselors were practicing on
emergency license 38 percent of licensed
clinical social workers 44 percent of
them sorry just a moment I mean there's
like a lot of information I'm trying to
is it all on some sort of handout that
we're gonna get no I can I I will email
you an overall presentation after the
fact the handouts will go along with
what I'm saying right if you could hand
that because I'd rather listen to you
than you know yeah okay yes
certainly
so in any event
um I think that the experiment that was
an emergency licensure certainly
supports the governor's proposal as does
HB 594 and we very much strongly support
um the proposal to allow for Universal
licensure recognition
um the second major proposed change is
to transfer certain boards to oplc those
being the board of actioners boxing and
wrestling professional bondsmen those
three are within the Secretary of
State's office and my understanding is
that the secretary of state does not
object to those transfers
there's also a proposal to transfer the
board of Licensing for interpreters for
the deaf deafblind and hard of hearing
from the Department of Education
um
in in truth the purpose of the transfers
is really to allow us to continue to
consolidate the administrative functions
regarding licensure that the state
already provides under oplc I've come
before you before to talk about some of
our major strategic goals one being to
achieve efficient operations by
leveraging technology obtain a new
licensing portal obtain a new CE broker
portal and then to establish Eternal
controls I think the governor's proposal
is intended to ensure that all licensed
individuals and or the agencies that
license those individuals have access to
the to this type of administrative
support
that would not otherwise be available if
they are operating on their own
so if I made a quick question before we
go on on what she's discussing now on
moving these
licenses out of the Secretary of State's
office I mean because we've had the
boxing one before and my question is why
are we removing
something that licenses events and not
professional licenses of individuals
that makes no sense to me that is not
what your office is set up to do
and that's why we voted this down in
this committee before and I still feel
strongly it doesn't belong
there again I totally agree this is a
completely different kind of license as
you stated representative it's an event
license is not at all like the other
licenses and we had this bill
and we kept it where it is for a reason
if I may representative
um the the boxing commission does
license people they license
um the referees they also license people
who are participating in these events
um my understanding is the criteria is
somewhat limited based on the
information I could find on their
website but they do license the
individuals in fact they have to female
female participants have to undergo
medical screening HIV tests pregnancy
tests prior to an event so there is a
certification process for the
individuals as well
question yeah
so are these people that are licensed
referees and so forth that is all New
Hampshire residents
I don't know that they're residents I
just know that in order to to
participate in these events in New
Hampshire you have to have a license and
it's my understanding that the boxing
commission did request this transfer
well I I think one of the things under
underlying principles without a follow
is that these things ought to be done
individually judgments ought to be made
on individual merits individual
circumstances and so forth as we're
discussing right at the moment and not
all loaded into a boxcar and shipped out
in one Festival yes representative
Schmidt I asked
the this was something that we would
have liked to have had before House Bill
2 was released but unfortunately we it
was too slow and we didn't have the time
to do it this
I understand every one of us has some
objection to some part of the the
structure I was would like to let
director Courtney continue explaining
the this is the overview of what's in
the governor wanted in House Bill 2 and
uh if you wish to
register an objection with the governor
or suggest to finance that something be
deleted
uh I will certainly support your doing
so
thank you I will certainly accept that
invitation but I only
jumped in on what representative goalie
was referencing with regard to the
boxing and and wrestling thing because I
do think there's a distinct difference
there especially if it turns out this
bunch of these people are not even New
Hampshire residents now you're licensing
somebody you know for a very specific
kind of thing we license people so that
they can work in New Hampshire not
necessarily because they are residents
I understand but I think there's a
distinction
I'll proceed on that note though I would
note that the legislature last year
repealed the administrative attachment
of the commission to the Secretary of
State's office so per 20 I think it's
RSA 21 they're technically attached to
the Das
but I don't think that's actually
happening so
at some point this body if not in this
bill may want to consider that
um in terms of proposed mergers that's
another major portion of House Bill 2
and as this committee is well aware as
proposed by House Bill 655 and hb2 oplc
is proposed to issue licenses in between
meetings in accordance with the rules
that are established by the boards this
really just codifies the practice that
currently exists for a large majority of
our licensing boards
because boards under that proposal would
no longer be reviewing
applic every application at monthly
meetings
there's really not necessarily a need
for such large bodies to do the work and
so in light of this decrease workload
hb2 proposes to merge certain boards
that are sufficiently similar to
increased efficiencies in the
administrative process
in particular hb2 proposes to merge The
Advisory Board of reflexology with The
Advisory Board of Massage Therapy
per our annual report just just so
you're aware there are only 17
reflexologists 12 structural integrators
and four Asian Bodywork therapists the
disciplines of reflexology are often
combined and just for your awareness you
have a handout
from the Reflexology Association it's
their National Association
outlining the fact that reflexology to
the extent that it is regulated is often
already merged with massage
next The Proposal proposes to merge
laidac with the boards of mental health
practice and the board of psychology
there are two states that currently
combine psychology with other
disciplines that being Kansas and Texas
and again I think given the fact that
mental health is one of those words are
one of the fee boards that actually
review applications at their monthly
meetings under proposed 655 they would
no longer be required to do that unless
there was a defect in the application
and so
um and so therefore the proposal would
propose to combine psychology with other
two other mental health disciplines
third the hb2 proposes to merge uh Board
of Medicine with Board of Podiatry
the New Hampshire Board of Medicine
currently regulates both MD's dos
osteopaths and physician assistance
11 states currently use one board to
regulate multiple disciplines including
Podiatry
I'm currently New Hampshire Board of
Podiatry is a five-member board and
they're only 91 podiatrists in New
Hampshire I know that the chair was here
the other day and expressed that there
had been I think over 40 complaints last
year
that really is because the board
previously never enforced their
continuing education requirements chose
to do so this year and 47 did not meet
them but it was really an anomaly in the
year prior to that they had only had one
complaint
and then finally hb2 proposes to merge
Engineers with land surveyors both
boards are currently supported by the
National Council of examiners for
engineering and surveying ncees 36
states have combined boards according to
ncees and only nine states have
Standalone engineering boards and those
states are for the most part fairly
larger
well I wouldn't say Delaware is too much
larger but there's Florida Illinois
Indiana Maine Maryland Michigan Vermont
and West Virginia have are the only
states that have stand-alone engineering
boards
another major change that's proposed in
House Bill 2 are um to move certain
boards to advisory boards
and as you may recall or some of you may
recall a seven I think it was six or
seven of our boards moved to the
advisory model last legislative session
this is the model that's currently used
by Vermont in particular but but there
are other states that utilize this model
and it's becoming
um increasingly trendy I should say on
the occupational licensing front really
to as a way to provide State super fight
super supervision
I've been just notified by the house
clerk that this is an illegal meeting
because there's a quorum of the
committee and it hasn't and it was not
known yes got it I'm aware of those
issues all too well so I apologize for
attempting to
um and please we would appreciate your
your backup data because uh we didn't
have time absolutely thank you for your
time and I apologize to the public for
not noticing this meeting thank you so
much